hey folks welcome to the Dark Horse
podcast I have the distinct pleasure of
sitting this morning with Jacob Shockey
who is founder and executive director of
the Beaver Coalition now many people
will not know what the beaver Coalition
is
uh I should probably say right at the
top that I know you because you were my
student and you were Heather student at
Evergreen how many years ago would that
have been yeah uh 2010 2010 that seems a
long that was a while coming there's
been some stuff that has happened since
2010 a bit of a different world uh yeah
it is uh it's a very different uh and in
many ways more troubling World in any
case Welcome To Dark Horse thank you for
having me uh glad to do it
um there's a lot that we might talk
about here
and many different topics that are
interrelated in various ways I will say
that this conversation is spurred by the
fact that you came to Portland you're
living in southern Oregon these days but
you came to Portland while Heather and I
and our family were living there
and you walked us around some Beaver
habitat and frankly what you told us
blew our minds we both know a bit about
beavers we were both Outdoors people who
have encountered them periodically know
about them from from some academic work
but what you said really changed our
understanding of the role that Beavers
play and have played in North America
and I thought it would be a really good
idea to bring that different perspective
to a much larger audience
so do you want to say something about
um how it is that those of us who think
we know something about beavers get it
wrong
yeah uh I'm surprised that it surprised
you but
um
they're not a very I mean they're kind
of an unassuming animal
um for a long time they were uh the
object of a lot of Desire because of
their pelts so a lot of a lot of people
spend a lot of time thinking about
beavers uh 150 250 years ago and then
for a while now they've been kind of a
pest species like sometimes they plug
culverts and
um
I think what's missed is that uh for for
thousands of years beavers were the
managers of the freshwater systems of
the Northern Hemisphere and
um they predictably
do things which we should get into to
the landscape
um
for their own needs and yet that
predictable way that they garden and
build a landscape
everything else has co-evolved to that
as that's how that's how streams look
that's how Rivers look when when they're
under Beaver management that that is
that is the the system that everything
has come to expect
and uh when beavers were absented from
that system
it it fell into a state that is very
different and that's the Baseline that
has shifted away
um you know even the the Meandering
stream that you imagine as a stream uh
one can make the argument that that's a
bit of a human construction
um
and so yeah I'm curious to hear like
what your model was prior to thinking
about beavers and and a landscape
context and
um well I've done a lot of thinking in
the aftermath of our conversation and
how could something that has such a
profound importance have escaped my
notice it's the kind of thing that I
pride myself on seeing and to understand
that I had had it wrong caused me to
wonder how that happened and what I've
come up with is
that the importance of beavers is
largely it's not even historical it's
prehistorical
and so I've been living my life in a
context that was thoroughly haunted by
animals that I was not seeing very
regularly and I think that that's the
Crux of it is you know I have
occasionally encountered beavers in the
wild but not often yeah and what that
led me to to correctly or incorrectly
think was that they had always been a
minor player and you know punching above
their weight class by virtue of the fact
that you know a small number of animals
can alter a habitat profoundly but my
thought was that's taking place where I
see a beaver pond and I was not
understanding that actually many of the
things that are not now Beaver ponds
have been dramatically impacted by past
Beaver activity and then further
impacted by the removal of those animals
both for fur and because people had
other plans for those pieces of land and
they didn't want a large rodent
deciding to terraform you know their
development or whatever it was that they
were doing our first sponsor for this
episode is mud water
mud water is a coffee alternative made
with four medicinal mushrooms yeah
mushrooms plus herbs and spices with 1 7
the caffeine of a cup of coffee you get
energy without the anxiety Jitters or
crash and it's delicious
each ingredient was added with intention
it has cacao and chai lion's mane
cordyceps chaga and Rishi turmeric and
cinnamon
is a terrific product you can drink it
black or with cream or honey or both
mud water also makes a non-dairy creamer
out of coconut milk and MCT and a
sweetener out of coconut palm sugar and
lucuma the fruit of an Andean tree used
by the Inca in the subjugation of their
neighbors
you can add those or mix and match a bit
of their coconut milk and MCT creamer
with some honey from your local bee
the flavor is warm and spicy with a hint
of chocolate plus Masala chai which
includes Ginger cardamom nutmeg and
cloves
try blending it into a smoothie with a
banana and Ice milk or a milk-like
substance mint and cacao nibs
it's utterly delicious they've got a
wonderful new caffeine free product
designed to drink before bed which is
also delightful
mud water is 100 USDA organic non-GMO
gluten-free vegan and kosher certified
Mata water allows you to build a morning
ritual that energizes without the crash
visit mudwater.com Darkhorse to support
the show and use Darkhorse at checkout
for 15 off that's
m-u-d-w-t-r.com slash Darkhorse use
Darkhorse at checkout for 15 off our
final sponsor for this episode is Vivo
barefoot shoes made for feet
regular listeners are well familiar with
Vivo by now but if you are not you're in
for a treat seriously try these shoes
most shoes are made for someone's idea
of feet not vivos Evils are made by
people with feet who know how to use
them here at Darkhorse we love these
shoes they are Beyond comfortable the
tactile feedback from the surfaces
you're walking on is amazing and they
cause no pain because there are no
pressure points forcing your feet into
odd positions they're truly fantastic
our feet are the products of millions of
years of evolution humans evolve to walk
move and run barefoot modern shoes that
are overly cushioned and strangely
shaped have negatively impacted foot
function and are contributing to a
Health crisis people move less than they
might in part because their shoes make
their feet hurt
enter Vivo barefoot Vivo barefoot shoes
are designed wide to provide natural
stability thin to enable you to feel
more and flexible to help you build your
natural strength from the ground up foot
strength increases by sixty percent in a
matter of months just by walking around
in them
the number of people wearing Vivo
barefoots is growing once people start
wearing these shoes they don't seem to
stop
Vivo Barefoot has a great range of
Footwear for kids and adults for every
activity from hiking to training and
they also have everyday wear they're a
certified B Corp that is pioneering
regenerative business principles and
their Footwear is produced using
sustainably sourced natural and recycled
materials with the aim to protect the
natural worlds you can run wild on it go
to vivobarefoot.com
Darkhorse to get an exclusive 20 off
additionally new customers get a 100 day
free trial so you can see if you love
them as much as we do that's
v-i-v-o-b-a-r-e-f-o-o-t.com slash
Darkhorse it was it was that that I had
wrong I thought that this was
comparatively rare animal and that just
simply isn't the case
so you want to talk about how common
they were yeah well so I come from uh I
I've lived a long time in this place
called the Applegate Valley it's uh
Southwestern Oregon and uh the the
native folks there called it the
and I'm probably butchering the
pronunciation but that was the Tacoma
word for this area and uh meant place of
the Beaver
and that was that was the first thing
that kind of alerted my attention
because there's it's a similar situation
as you describe where there's an
occasional Beaver you know but you
wouldn't name it the place of the beaver
and it's it's fertile Farm Fields it's a
kind of narrow Valley with fertile Farm
fields and a river or stream on one side
or the other or maybe the middle you
know little bands of trees on both sides
um
not very beavery right uh but
there's a history there of gold mining
um this this place there was a huge rush
that came in and this Valley was full of
gold
and I got to thinking about that in the
context of well this Valley was also
full of beaver and miners use this thing
called a sluicebox right and it's
basically a bunch of ridges that catches
heavy metal that settles out and
um sediment settles out too and so this
Valley is flat and fertile because of
this the aggregate settling out of
sediment over thousands and thousands of
years behind beaver dams but those
beaver dams in this context were also
catching the gold that eroded from the
hillsides and so you know the first Rush
of folks through this area were the
beaver Trappers the second Rush of folks
through this area were the gold miners
and they were
they were harvesting the The Spoils of
thousands of years of accumulated wealth
behind beaver dams and that's really
what fertile valleys that we Farm have
done too we we drained wetlands
and we uncovered this fertility
um but it's the fertility it's the it's
the Vestige of this this Beaver Kingdom
um and we took streams and pushed them
over to the side of the hill and uh you
know made them the ditches that we see
today
so uh to unpack this a little bit
the you know where there's this cliche
about gold in them with our Hills and
the idea really I mean let's take it all
the way back as long as as long as we're
doing this right gold is not produced by
anything here on Earth it's incapable of
being produced by anything here on Earth
it is produced by supernovas right it
gets spewed into the universe by
exploding stars and then gravity draws
stuff together not just gold a small
fraction of it being gold and that gold
and silver and platinum and all of the
other stuff gets kind of haphazardly
molded into some ball right a planet
and the point is that planet isn't
perfectly flat because there are
processes that push some parts up and
other parts you know erode away and that
results in a process where all of these
heavy things are distributed at
arbitrary Heights and then gravity
slowly Works them down presumably into
the Seas but if you have a beaver
doing its beaver thing then the point is
well that actually creates this loose
box is that the term yeah so you've got
the sluice box being produced by a
rodent that has no interest in gold at
all right but the point is there's a
deposit of gold there that is not the
result of the fact that the process of
supernovas and then the gravity pulling
the stuff of the earth together it
didn't put that stuff in that Valley
beavers put in that Valley and so this
first place where some huge amount of
wealth
is the result of this rodents activity
and then of course there's a gold rush
which you know I've never heard beavers
mentioned as an important feature of the
gold rush in my life but of course they
were Central to it yeah key contractors
for thousands of years there you go
would you say key contractors are
pre-contractors right so anyway so the
point is I know all about the gold rush
I grew up in California I didn't know
that beavers were an important chapter
in that story and what I find out is
that that's actually the minor piece of
it right right gold is one thing but
there's also the fact of the fertility
of the West which is a result of a
parallel process that is Downstream of
literally Downstream of exactly the same
activity of this
absolutely remarkable rodent yeah yeah
yeah and we have an interesting
relationship with it because I feel like
we look at it as a fellow ecosystem
engineer and there's a bit of admiration
you know we've got a busy as a beaver
and right all this stuff but we also
have some disagreements around the
Landscaping right we have not agreed on
Blueprints and so when it starts
architecting if we have other designs on
that piece of land we consider it a
nuisance yeah it's it's troubling It's
upsetting uh to our sensibilities and
the thing is you know we've
we've taken these flat lands and we've
assumed that
those Flatlands are stable as they are
we don't quite see that these these
fertile fields that we've been
harvesting that fertility and you know
food
um
that's a that's a system that has been
degraded to that state and so I spend a
lot of my time kind of helping folks
with Beaver issues it's because they've
then brought in houses and Roads and all
these various things and they've built
it on these vestiges of wetlands and uh
and gravity being what it is
um when beavers show up in that context
and they start to build back the dams uh
you sometimes have cities and
subdivisions in the way
um and a lot of what I do when I'm
talking with like a city to planning
department is just to point out Simply
like okay well be careful where it's
flat
because a lot of what we're seeing right
now
um
you know a family's been farming a piece
of land in Oregon for maybe five
generations and they've been farming
right to the water's edge the water has
been ditched into a stream
um and then all this fertility is
growing food and what have you and then
when that sells to subdivisions uh like
on in the urban sprawl we do this thing
where we where we say well now we're
going to make the stream pristine we're
going to plant trees along it and those
are going to filter the runoff from all
of our you know impervious surfaces and
when we plant trees that was the thing
the beaver were missing
that was good Beaver habitat and they
were just missing the trees the farmer
was asked ingredients yeah and so then
they move in and they bring that water
back up to where they would expect it to
be and
um things get flooded and so there's
this cycle that's happening across the
West now with Urban expansion that's
actually facilitating more Beaver
habitat and these and these systems that
have been you know the the nerdy biology
term right at the limiting factors uh
the the trees were limiting
well so this is a a beautiful story and
a tragic story in many ways because
um isn't it marvelous at one level that
you've got this creature that's
literally responsible for making the
bottom lands flat and rich and full of
gold and all sorts of other things that
we like and we've made it very
inhospitable to them by shooting at them
and terraforming in our own ways and
ripping out their dams and draining
their wetlands and all these things but
some part of us
still has a you know a Vestige of that
land is good because it's aesthetically
nice right that's a proxy for good land
right how would you know that you didn't
settle here well it might be that it
looks very beautiful to you and that is
actually an indicator and it has all the
stuff you're probably going to want so
you know we like it
when the stream has some trees right
that looks good to us and it looks good
to the beaver you put the trees there
and holy moly you've just Unleashed this
animal that's responsible for all of the
wealth that you're profiting from and
your senses oh my God that's terrible
right like indeed oh no those trees well
I'll hear that even from folks who are
restoration professionals and they they
put in the trees and you know then I get
the call like the Beavers are in here
cutting down my trees
um and these are folks with some title
like Wildlife biologists or what have
you but the the knee-jerk reaction
sometimes can be like trap out the
Beavers you know right there's there's a
disconnect that these are like if you do
restoration and beavers show up you met
the beaver standard like congratulations
you just your restoration project worked
it did you know you can hand it off to
the professionals now they're going to
run with it right and and you're right
about you know this is why a good
biological model is really what you want
because in some sense it's not really
surprising that you would sometimes be
one ingredient short of perfect habitat
for something like a beaver right and if
you don't think about it in those terms
right you think well there are no
beavers here it's probably not good and
it's like no you're real close right and
if you put that one thing there boom
there's almost nothing you can do to
stop this next part of the process which
you might not like
um but it is uh
well let's just say it is an incredibly
powerful force that's really to the
extent that some of us have been and I
you know even though I missed this
aspect of them having transformed much
of North America I have been fascinated
by this animal for a long time because
the
[Music]
um
the disproportionate capacity to affect
the world around it a small number of
individuals being able to radically
alter a habitat and turn it for example
from you know a a rushing stream into a
small Lake right that's an amazing
capacity for an animal and then you know
if you told me there was such an animal
I wouldn't leap to the conclusion that
it was going to be a rodent right a
small number of individual rodents are
going to build me a lake right that
seems odd right this is not um
it's not the clade that I would go to if
I was looking for an animal that you
know I mean how hard would it be if
somebody assigned you know in your case
you've spent enough time with beavers
that maybe you do a good job but if you
gave the average person the job of make
me a lake here and you gave them a saw
to drop down some trees and you said you
could put the trees how you want and you
can mud up the spaces in between you
know most people would not be able to
create a lake and yet
this animal unders it's not just that it
chops down trees and uses them to block
water flows and that that creates Lakes
it's that it apparently each one of
these valleys is its own
puzzle and it solves that puzzle indeed
right each time it figures out how to do
it and and it does it collectively as a
family which is also interesting so
let's get into this let's let's just
fill in the natural history of beavers
so that people understand uh what a
remarkable and strange creature this is
so we can start with family right
um
they seem to mate for life
um you've got a mom and a dad and
not very sexually dimorphic you can't
really tell the difference
um some biologists have figured out a
method you turn the beaver upside down
and you squeeze their butt and you sniff
and it either smells like diesel or
cheese
and really yeah so you know a true
Beaver biologist yeah I know the diesel
or cheese
um yeah so I can't really tell Mom or
Dad apart
um then they'll have like two to four
young ones on average uh a year and they
The Young Ones stick around for a year
or two so you've got teenagers helpers
okay so some colonies can be 12
individuals or more
um and they're territorial they've got a
an area of vegetation and water that
they're managing actively
and uh
and they manage it together I mean I
guess that's what made me think about it
is you're thinking about you know this
animal intelligently building a
um a dam
it's 12 animals it's even better
intelligently building it's
intelligently collaborating on a project
in which everybody's got to do their
part right yep and there's no foreman
right and they do a lot of digging too
so so Beaver they're very graceful in
the water
um they're not graceful on land and
they're they can be 60 pounds of
slow-moving protein right I mean
anything they can would love to eat a
beaver so they flood Landscapes to stay
protected from predators uh wolves were
a big Predator
um historically yeah Bears big predator
in my area cougars are probably one of
them the main Predator
um aside from of course humans now right
um and in my area the humans were a
predator for a long time too beavers
were eaten
um
so you've got this this tight-knit
family they are interested in keeping
the big kitties at Bay by flooding the
landscape right yep and
um depending on the landscape then
they'll build a structure to live in and
if they flooded the landscape all the
way to the sides of the valley
well then you know they don't breathe
underwater they need a dry space they'll
build themselves up a lodge and it's
this freestanding mound of sticks and
mud and it has an underwater entrance
right kind of a front door and sometimes
it'll have mini cavities in it sometimes
they have kind of a mud room like dry
your feet off and then come up to the
main chamber I think I know which Beaver
thought of that
it's the mother yeah no there's no
reason no track all that mud into the
rest of the lodge yep I've I've crawled
up into one of these one time and they
uh they smell lovely like like crushed
Willow
um do they really yeah yeah beavers kind
of have a willowy scent
um yeah it's not the rodent scent that
triggers the human brain like oh this is
something that yep could give me a
disease that rat scent yeah I know
there's none of that there's not even an
undertone of that it's a crushed Willow
smell yeah that's great that's
surprising to me yeah but but I get it
okay so they've got the big enough
chamber for you to get in indeed yeah
and you're not tiny no not tiny I'm
crazy enough to crawl into a Beaver
Lodge yeah apparently yeah so so they
have this this lovely little Lodge and
and in areas that um freeze over winter
they'll pack a bunch of vegetation down
in their Pond
um as a Larder to eat off of Once the
ice forms so this is wood or woody woody
material yeah so the uh the environment
uh softens it up over time or no you
know there's there's discussion around
like uh
what it sitting in the water does right
you know
um the the main hypothesis for a long
time has just been like accessibility
when the ice forms got it right well
that certainly makes a prediction that
where the ice doesn't form they will do
less or none of it yep and we see that
kind of borne out we do yeah cool yeah
um they also they uh
kind of a knock-on effect of this
collection of wood so you think about a
rodent that's obsessively taking
vegetation from outside the stream yeah
adding it into the stream so
um just for the sake of filling this in
for people who haven't spent much time
in Beaver habitat yeah you've got
beavers will put in a investment over
what must be
weeks on a very large log right I've
seen that oh I see one big tree one big
tree so it has to be on the shore and
has to be leaning in such a way that
they can predict that it will fall into
the water enough that they can then swim
it to wherever they it's a lot easier if
it falls in the water a lot easier if it
falls in the water there's presumably
nothing they can do with a large tree if
it falls out of the water they will
utilize it
um so but they can't move it they can't
move it yeah but they'll Buck it up
um yes I've never seen that yeah that's
cool so how long a length will they Buck
is uh when you cut a
um a log into rounds before you split it
into pieces yeah so if you're making
firewood yep 16 inches right yeah and
it's funny because beaver and I don't
know why seem to prefer a similar it
looks like cord wood except for the
taper not the end you know
and you can you can spot a spot where a
tree has been felled and bucked because
there's the wood chips at approximately
every 16 inches which you would totally
if you didn't know what was going on
probably assume implied human
involvement yeah they do look a little
like somebody was whacking at something
with a hatchet right so beavers have
these these really impressive teeth they
grow continuously yeah for the beaver's
life which is true of all rodents yeah
and the front of them are orange
um which I I from what I understand
there's like a heavy iron component that
keeps that front Dentin
um hard yep and so there's self
sharpening yep uh these these little uh
chisels
um and it's it's impressive they they
can fill very big trees now why they
choose sometimes to fill Big Trees is
interesting you know uh beavers being
territorial they'll be managing a wood
lot if you will a riparian area of trees
and shrubs and the grasses and Forbes
through their lineage through
generations
sometimes they'll pass up a tree for
many many many years and then one day
it's like that's the tree
so why do they do it
well I don't have a good example of our
explanation for you know there's
something more complicated going on so
what you're saying is you see a pattern
in which there is obviously some sort of
I don't I'm not arguing it's conscious
we don't know how beaver's mind yes but
there's intentionality choice to now I
fell that one and it could be that it is
managing the habitat right in other
words you liberate other trees that are
struggling to get enough light for
example by felling a big tree and that
might be the reason that that one goes
and so again this might be a
management issue of parameters that make
the habitat more productive of things
that the Beavers are eating or and
there's a whole conversation with the
plant too and the chemical defenses that
plants put out to avoid
browsers right so every plant has their
various phenolic compounds and whatever
that they're spending some budget of
energy on chemical defense so we will uh
this audience the Dark Horse audience
will have heard Heather uh and Me Talk
many times about secondary compounds
these are compounds that don't have a
function inside the the plant or the
fungus or whatever that is producing
them their purpose is to interact with
animals usually to um to poison them so
that they will move on and eat something
else so anyway and they taste bitter
right you know animals have developed
the taste of this we have evolved the
ability to detect these oh that's a
poison yeah exactly and in fact um you
know as you know you've been to the the
tropics
um and you know there's lots of things
out there that are obviously fruits but
it's not obvious whether or not you can
eat them right um but there is a trick
which is you know you take a little
fruit yeah put it on your tongue and if
it tastes bitter you don't eat that
thing and if it tastes good then you can
uh gently explore it proceed with
caution yes this trick has never killed
me yeah not yet at least not yet not yet
you being here right that is a proof
good evidence so far it has worked
um yeah well beavers do the same thing
sometimes you'll see them nicking into a
tree you'll see like one Little Neck and
they didn't they didn't choose to cut
that tree and then you'll see three or
four necks along and then that well
somebody's coming down and and an
interesting thing too is it seems to be
you know if your plant and you're low
you're expecting more browsers and so
you're going to spend more of your
energy producing these phenolic
compounds these bitter tannins to keep
browsers at Bay but as you grow High
well that that doesn't make sense to
spend all that budget anymore on
chemical defense because you're above
the height of the grazers and browsers
and so beavers kind of come in and
um subvert that by whacking the tree
down yeah and then they'll eat all the
foil foliage in the cambium layer from
the massive tree that stops spending
money or energy energy on these on these
poisons yeah that is so interesting and
that you can watch the deer come in
everybody loves it when a beaver drops a
big tree because suddenly you have a
very sweet
uh food source sitting there
um that's mind-blowing actually no it
makes perfect sense why why defend
against the browsers if you're tall and
they exactly you but the beaver has this
other you know it's a little bit of
chisels yeah it's reminiscent to me of
the way a Strangler fig reverses the
tables on the other trees in a tropical
forest where you know in general the
problem for every tree in a tropical
forest is you start out on the forest
floor where there's almost no light like
one percent of the incident light
actually makes it to the forest floor
and you've got to wait an awful long
time before a gap opens up right and so
most would-be trees just die of light
starvation
before they ever get a chance and
Strangler figs uh start well at least
often at the top they start you know a
bat will uh eat a fig and drop a seed in
you know a crevice and a tree that's
accumulated some dirt and the tree grows
down from above where there's plenty of
light and now it has a water problem
weirdly but
um but anyway this strikes me as that
same sort of thing where the natural
logic of the forest has been out thunk
by one creature and there are all sorts
of consequences
um for other creatures of oh well
suddenly that tree just came you know
though vibrant and alive just came
crashing out of the canopy and you can
browse it temporarily that's really cool
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah and it seems
consistent with some of the observations
I've made too where sometimes you'll
walk a section and it it seems like
there should be Beaver here and you'll
see sign that beavers have moved through
but they haven't decided to settle you
know there's plenty of water it seems
like a good spot and I'm seeing lots of
green things yeah but then you go look
at the green things and consistently I
see this in areas with like heavy elk
brows or cat public land cattle grazing
brows where you you look at the the
typical plants beavers would be eating
and they've been munched and munched and
munched and munched and they've got this
kind of like dwarfed Bonsai look going
and my mind immediately says well that's
a very bitter plant right that is a
plant that has responded with toxins and
it's probably not worth the Beavers it's
probably not worth so so to our human
Minds we're looking at lots of green
stuff but yeah I feel like there's
there's this underlying conversation
between the plants and the browsers
that's really interesting and it does
there is one observation in a completely
different system
um that I wonder if it might not be
related cool so back when I used to
study tent making bats
by far by far like by 10 or 20 times you
would find empty tents
um you know and one in 20 times you
might find a bat in the tent or a family
of bats
but then also in addition to all of the
empty tents and the empty tents have a
relatively straightforward answer
explanation
which is that the bats are moving on to
where this was the hypothesis I tested
while I was doing my dissertation work
was that these bats all of the tent
making bats are small and they pay a
high price for Locomotion the bigger bat
you are the more efficient a flyer you
are and so flying long distances is
expensive for these animals and so they
are placing tents near the fruiting
trees
um but you know a tree might be in fruit
for a week or two and then it's not in
fruit and having a tent there isn't all
that useful so it moves on so there's
lots of empty tanks because they're
always in motion yeah but there's also
this other phenomenon of partially built
tents that never get completed and you
know presumably sometimes that's the
result of the animal having started
something and then being consumed by a
predator sure all right but there are
too many of them for it to be that and I
wonder if there aren't you know I
wondered if some of it might be practice
you know the building intent they build
them in uh well when I was working on
Barrow Colorado Island I was there for
18 months and there was literally only
two species of understory plant with a
large enough Leaf to make a tent that I
never saw a tent made in
and so they're making them in broadly
hundreds of differences of plants which
have different Leaf shapes and so right
and they're chewing into the little Vine
right and they're collapsing the
structure of the leaf they're mostly
using the um the claws at the tips of
their thumbs and they're using their
flight muscles which are their strongest
muscles to tear the leaf nobody knew
this because nobody had seen a bat make
a tent I did manage to see it and
actually videotape it and it's the
pulling with the thumbs and the claws
and it's one leaf that's been kind of
collapsed onto itself well there are a
bunch of different structures that's one
of them that's that's one of the more
common ones but there are a bunch of
different structures including one
really cool structure in which they cut
a bunch of different leaflets on the
same whirl and cause a kind of a
cylinder but anyway it's a
there's a lot of partially completed
tents and I you know I have wondered
about whether it's practice right
learning to build a tent and some leaf
that you've never built one in before
um but it is also possible that there is
something about toxins right now it's
unclear that they do very much uh with
their mouths so maybe they're not being
toxified that way but it is possible
that the plant is releasing something
you know when they uh tear into it and
that is that is noxious or something so
anyway totally yeah I think I think
that's a spot that we often don't think
to look right yes and the plant would
only be doing that if they have an
interest and no bats sleeping here
tonight right that is a well
certainly the process of tent building
is destructive of the plants it's
wasteful it's parasitic from the plant's
perspective okay um the quano that's
accumulated isn't a trade-off
probably there's some benefit but I
can't imagine it's worth the expense of
losing these large leaves I mean for one
thing these large leaves you know I know
because I watched leaves get modified
and then you know I watched what
happened to them afterwards so I was
sort of aware of individual leaves these
leaves are you know Investments or that
last for years right and so that's a big
loss in the case of a small understory
plant with a big leaf so anyway but we
digress we are so far away from from
beavers here
um no beavers in Central or South
America no I mean there are some other
interesting things but they got moved
down there it's a bit of a problem is
that true yeah I haven't seen them oh
yeah the Patagonia beavers oh I guess
that makes sense yeah far enough that's
a landscape that did not co-evolve with
lagering and so what has happened well
so you see the the plants drown and die
and there's these large deserts of water
and vegetation death
wow which is completely the reverse of
what you see in the entire Northern
Hemisphere Europe and North America
where you just see this explosion of
life like everything's like oh thank
goodness that's so fascinating yeah and
and it's it's a it's a beautiful
demonstration of two things that Heather
and I talk a lot about on Dark Horse one
is welcome to complex systems right just
because the this animal is a uh a source
of bounty in one habitat doesn't mean
that it's a source of bounty inherently
right right it can be a destructive yes
elsewhere which is really uh
um interesting
and it's also a question of
hyper novelty here where you know a
beaver from North America isn't going to
find its way to Patagonia absent human
help
right but uh once you provide that help
I would imagine it's pretty difficult
creature to remove we've been helpful
that way with a lot of animals and yes
Beaver their fur being as luxurious as
it was we we thought it was a good idea
I wanted to ask you about that I do want
to finish out the natural history story
but um in general when a creature has a
particularly cool Pelt there's a reason
right so in the case of otters which I
see otters which have the densest fur of
any mammal I believe
um it's a wetsuit yeah right and the
point is you've got a small animal who
is in cold water and would radiate away
all of its heat it wouldn't be possible
to have that otter if it wasn't
effectively not in the water because
it's wearing a wetsuit that is so dense
that it is actually keeping the skin
from contacting the water all right so
what's going on with beavers same same
exact thing that you laid out and in
fact that's why their pelts were worth
so much it wasn't uh worth a lot on the
leather if you will
um these pelts were being shaved
and then that that under fur that
densely packed was being felted and
that's Abe Lincoln hat you know the
tallest of pipette those things held
moisture at Bay and heat in because it
was the felted under fur of beavers and
so I felt it I'd never understood that
yeah the mat is a Hatter thing is
because they were using Mercury Mercury
yeah yep so it's it's felted I knew
about the Mercury I did not know that
that was uh Beaver felt indeed yeah so
that that whole period where it was
fashionable to wear a black hat uh of a
certain shape and really silk the the
influx of silk from Asia saved the
remnants of the Beaver population in
this continent uh because then fashion
fickly turned to Silk and uh and there
were some some refugees left on the
Landscapes there seems to be no end to
the number of things I didn't know about
these animals um that is that is amazing
I assumed that the pelts were being used
in the I mean people make coats and
stuff too with the fur but right the
real use and and still today uh the Best
Western hats you can buy are you know
how I don't know how much you've worn a
cowboy hat but there's an X system like
it's a 1x hat a 2X hat you know you have
a 10x hat and the X's got weird now
they're saying it's 100x it doesn't
matter that's grading on how much beaver
fur there is versus rabbit and some
other animals really yeah it's a it's a
percentage of you know you're you're
really bawling if you got a 100 beaver
fur because that was very expensive to
manufacture but it also means it's the
best hat
um interesting you know whereas a 10x
you know you're working up yeah well I
have a hat that people take to be a
cowboy hat and they give me a lot of
crap over it it's a leather hat which is
freaking marvelous for the field because
it uh you know it can be pouring and the
thing just keeps the rain away from you
and you can you know it needs a little
work and you can put avocado oil on it
or whatever it's a great hat but it
ain't it ain't uh Beaver felt or
anything related to it yeah
um okay so let's let's go back to the
Natural History of these animals so
they build a lodge pair mates for Life
yeah I didn't finish out the lodge story
yeah so so in a context where they've
been successful and they've laterally
you know across a valley wedded the
system and they've got this spongy
Wetland of habitat yeah it's growing all
this stuff that they're eating and
um then they have to build a lodge but
if they're in a system where there's a
high Bank convenient to deep water then
they can just build a tunnel up into
that bank and it saves a lot of effort
and so a lot of times you also see
beavers Denning in Banks where they can
create that air pocket usually they'll
choose to den under the root structure
of some big deciduous tree to help avoid
Predators digging in on them right that
Andrew provides like this the lattice
work of wood wood bowl works against
digging Predators also sort of strikes
me as uh reminiscent of the Shoring up
of mine shafts uh yeah totally it looks
that way you know you got this this
these arching Timbers over a hollowed
out space I don't know what the tree
thinks about having all that activity
under it but uh they often they'll often
choose to go
do that and we see more of that in the
context of today's landscape because of
course many of our Creeks have collapsed
into these systems where you like look
down at the creek from up on the flat
which is just an unnatural thing not
normal huh yeah not in the northern
hemisphere interesting so
um
what would it look like
well so you read some of the the Old
Trapper journals right like how do we
peer back into the Misti past okay well
our Baseline for what this is skewed
what you can't go to grinnell's journals
the the naturalist who came through and
um kind of recorded what he was seeing
because that was post Beaver trapping
you know so you've got a little bit on
on trapping journals and and some of the
maps that were being produced and
you know just some of the accounts where
you'll hear about a party that would
come into come off of a ridge top and
they get to a valley and they'd spend a
day or two trying to find a spot to
cross across the valley because it's
just one Epic beavers Wetland yeah it's
just a spongy
wild world and they would find usually a
beaver dam to cross and these beaver
dams had persisted in the landscape so
long that you could actually walk horses
and wagons across these things these
things were wide wow and so deeply
rooted do you have a mill obviously
you're telling me it's a little hard to
figure it out because the evidence
wasn't well preserved but any idea how
long
A History A Beaver Dam that you could
take horses and and uh yeah right like
how how old how old is that yeah yeah
well that gets into kind of
um
do these things get passed down we know
they get passed down right we've got
these families that are tending these
things
um but it's
it's not as simple as uh you know you've
got your natal family and they defend it
against all others there's many accounts
of actually Beaver families taking in
refugees
um even some of the early accounts from
150 years ago there's um this one author
he knows Mills describes this account
where uh Wildfire came through an area
and
um one of the places beavers were living
was very pitchy and the the trees were
close and it cracked all their lodges
open and it destroyed the habitat and
there's a number of like 30 beavers
living in this spot and then a few miles
away down a drainage and up another
drainage there's another habitat where
beavers are living but they've they've
successfully created that sponge that
buffered them from the fire completely
the fire got down to the water it didn't
burn we moved on and they had a
um a spot there that was working and he
tracked the Beavers whose habitat had
been completely destroyed as they went
down the stream looking for a new spot
but then turned right and went up and
over the hill at exactly the point where
it was the shortest distance to the
um the habitat that was across the Ridge
and then down and
uh join the beavers and the pond that
had survived and so you and there was no
sign of conflict like it right so so we
don't know you know how these things are
passed we know that there's these
familial ties right um we know there's
these these territories and these um I
don't know how long a B I mean these
things grow roots too because you think
about Willow right yeah beavers are
clipping it into little segments and
they're jamming it into these these dams
that are built of mud and Willow sticks
and then those Willow sticks root okay
yeah the Willows have gotten why is that
you can you can plant a willow from uh
cutting and it's not effectively doing
that yeah and so and a dam that's only
even three years old will be starting to
literally root into the landscape
um so let me ask you so there are so
many things I want to ask you
um obviously nobody knows in that case
of these beavers who were taken in as
refugees my prediction based on what I
think I know about biology will be that
they were closely related
um sure but it's also possible that
reciprocal altruism could do it where um
the Beavers that had that piece of
habitat that had functioned
um
uh could you know if they were limited
in their reproductive rate and they
could have used the labor of more
beavers than they had it's possible it's
a little hard to imagine that because
you would think that beavers could
produce enough uh baby beavers to right
to fill up that
um that Valley but in any case something
interesting has to be there's
interesting stuff that we don't
understand there's there's a lot of
accounts of
um digging a canal to move water into a
different system to then build a dam and
flood to access like say you've got a
really great all uh stand of Aspen over
here yeah right but the stream is
intermittent there's not enough to damn
to get to the Aspen there's many
accounts of beavers they dig canals
across the landscape and they'll divert
water into an adjacent system then
utilize that water by building a dam and
then log out the Aspen Grove and again
they're doing this with no Foreman it's
like Flume yeah yeah sure yeah I can now
yeah no that's uh that's beautiful and
um you know as you probably remember
from class back in 2010 or whatever
um one of the things I'm interested in
is
ways that Evolution solves longer term
problems than you would think it could
right based on lineage selection and
Explorer modes and so anyway this
strikes me as a as a good a good case
that one might go pursue those things
and and discover that
um you know what has to be true for the
reward of you know investing in a canal
to a habitat that isn't wet enough you
know pays off well that can very easily
be true if you're dealing with a lineage
level indeed phenomenon for sure yeah
yeah and to your point about age of
Beaver Dam too
um there's this this stream called spawn
Creek outside Logan Utah and uh when you
go walk up it there's there's a number
of beaver dams and it's a very high
gradient Creek so they'll build a 12
foot tall Beaver Dam and it doesn't buy
them a lot of pond before they need to
build another Beaver right because the
the stream is steep enough that where is
it like in a low gradient valley you can
build a two foot Beaver Dam and get
acreage right right so you walk up this
stream and then you'll notice that
there's these stair steps of calcium
um in the Stream as well and they're
they're these funny things they're like
these benches of calcium
um hypothesis being those are are more
or less fossilized beaver dams the
calcium carbonate precipitated out over
a very long period of time and Aspen
being what they are that that being has
been there for a very long time and so
beavers have been there
too this makes some I've wondered about
this looking at uh Beaver ponds for so
long how
they it's like they are a standing wave
right and you know you have to start
thinking in terms of an equilibrium
and you have to start thinking about uh
you know I mean
um Dawkins of course uses beavers to
elucidate his concept of uh of extended
phenotype which I think is actually it's
a great concept yeah
um and beavers really are a tremendous
Exemplar of this where you know if
you're just looking at the animal you're
really not looking at the animal because
the animal is all of the consequences of
the animal that make the animal possible
Right including making its own little
Lakes right that's
um
amazing thing but if you then project it
through time and the point is well you
know a lake once made is valuable
at lineage level and a lake once made is
a way of bootstrapping your way to some
location that was
too far to be useful right the
possibilities that are opened by an
animal that can terraform and can do so
over centuries or potentially Millennia
is it's a very powerful force much more
so than you know the road from which
it's built indeed yeah and some of us
use the term Beaver as a verb sometimes
that system has been beef and beavered
yeah yeah I mean kind of Dawkins
portrayal of it the animal is bigger
than the furry thing you're seeing yep
um a system that is beavered that that
brings a lot of explanation as to how
that complex system is working
um right and we have in some sense
anti-beavered these systems now right
you have unambiguously but not just by
removing the Beavers we have in fact
done so on the one hand you've got who
knows
presumably it's millions of years that
beavers have been modifying these
landscapes at least since the last ice
age right but but the Beavers didn't
evolve since the last ice age so the
point is there's some ebb and flow and
most of the
um
uh glaciation was you know up around the
American Canadian border so it's not
like North America was completely
inaccessible to these animals at all
even even during glaciation so we're
talking about millions of years of um
these creatures modifying habitats and
sediments accumulating with their gold
and their nutrients and all of these
things and then
um of course you know you have a couple
of influxes of people you have the
discovering of America from the East
well actually from the West first right
from what we call the East right Asians
who have come through yeah
um and uh you know developed into so
many different cultures in the Americas
and then you have the second influx of
Europeans who ReDiscover America and
um intensively exploit it in a way that
not only did they trap out the Beavers
for hats and the like but
we have now taken to intensively
extracting resources the the
technological revolution has allowed us
to produce you know with the Haber Bosch
process we can fertilize crops and they
grow ferociously we can irrigate them we
can exterminate their pests but the
point is
um
you forgot about equilibrium right right
there were some things that you're
depending on and you're now spending
them down and topsoil is absolutely one
of these things right we are in a
topsoil crisis and we are increasingly
close to effectively growing our food
hydroponically in dead soils that we
then pump nutrients that are the product
of an industrial process rather than a
biological process right and you know in
some sense that's what happens when you
view the Beavers as a phenomenon limited
to that little or not so little bundle
of brown fur rather than as a landscape
altering equilibrium maintaining force
of nature well we can even say weather
changing oh please please tell us about
the weather changing well so you know
the uh
hydrologic cycle that you know you learn
when you're a kid and that's then you
relearn it and you relearn it's like
chemical illness like the salmon cycle
where people like to put it on a graph
but basically uh you know water
evaporates in the ocean forms clouds
comes over land rains moves it back out
on stream yep right that's a pump yep
and what drives that pump well one of
the things that's most important in
driving that pump is vegetative
transpiration
right so you've got you've got trees and
they do it most where it's a wetland
breathing this moist air up and that's
that's a or a lack of pressure rather
that draws in the clouds off the ocean
yeah um and there's there's some
wonderful work on this this guy
Professor me on me on it has been
working in Spain around this
um I think it's sometimes is called the
term biotic pump
um but you've got a cycle where you've
got the land pulling the moisture up out
of the out of the sea and it's really
the it's it's how much moisture you're
putting up there that creates that
pressure or lack of pressure that draws
in the clouds and so beaver Islands
that's that's where you get most of your
vegetative transpiration so and
you take that out yeah you've got less
and you put up in a parking lot you've
got even less and you can imagine these
rain Pathways that have been thousands
of years of rain Pathways and there's a
certain thing that maintain that pump
and then we make land use decisions and
we start doing things like turning these
Wetlands that were facilitating that
pump into crop lands where we're keeping
things on life support yeah and more or
less it's functioning as a desert as far
as what it's giving back to the air most
of the year and you can see how we're
going to start break seeing the
breakdown and we've seen the breakdown
in rain patterns and you know you can
even look at in mythology in Iran
um one of the the rules was you never
kill a water dog they call the Beavers
the water dogs because a drought will
follow you know back to your like useful
mythologies right they had they had laws
on the park like you killed a water dog
and there was severe penalties you had
to pay a restitution tuition
and similar thing within the indigenous
communities of North America the the
Trappers that came in had a really hard
time persuading any of the tribes that
were in drought prone areas to trap
beaver
they got the forest tribes
to sign on board much sooner than any of
the tribes that were sensitive and and
and and most of those folk had stories
that maintained a
um uh rule against over harvesting
beaver
because then you then you lose the
system that's me I mean I hunt I people
who I will tell you
the productivity is there at Beaver
Wetlands like that's where the fish are
that's where the game is like you're
hungry yeah go to a beaver Wetland yeah
right and so this this ecological wealth
um is not only the beaver it's not only
the landscape
um but it's also driving these these
patterns that
or even more reliant on yeah so it it's
interesting if you think about you know
the the the thing that we teach about uh
effectively evaporation
um creating humidity the cloud gets to
the mountain it rises it cools the water
falls out it runs back down eventually
ends in the sea all true
um but what you're saying is how quickly
it returns to the sea has a lot to do
with whether or not there are beavers in
between because the Beavers effectively
for their own benefit detain the water
they detain the water in a way that not
only does it sit there in these
artificial ponds and lakes but
um it incentivizes the growth of plants
that are useful to the beaver which then
take that water and spread it out
vertically so it's not like a big
a bundle of water with a small surface
area but it effectively has a huge
surface area yes right and then the sun
vertically down too because gravity
being what it is you block up water
that's trying to move downhill and
you're going to start recharging your
ground right recharging the groundwater
which is so excited about the stretching
out of these processes
um I'm tempted I won't detain us but um
you know as you also may remember from
class
um
I used to joke about the fact that my
bicycle was gravity Fusion do you
remember the internet yes and the basic
punch line of that whole story is that
all of this stuff almost no matter what
including things like
um uh like nuclear fission are solar
powered right
um they may not have been powered by our
sun but they were powered by a star and
the basic point is you could tell that
whole story you could look at all of the
different places where energy from uh
this you know gravity Fusion reactor in
the sky is pumping this water around in
these waves that establish equilibria
that will allow you to return to that
Wetland and Hunt there for uh
effectively eternity right or to farm
there if you are careful to allow
something to restore those equilibria
and then if you just ignore those things
and you say well you know how high can
we drive the rate of productivity up and
the answer is pretty damn High
temporarily right right well and if we
were talking about residence time in
that cycle another component of that is
if you don't have
the draw then you still have
water vapor hanging out over the ocean
but it just can't go anywhere right
right that's a that's a powerful
greenhouse effect right Professor Miriam
uses the number 40 times more powerful
than CO2 yeah you know I don't know but
you've got suddenly a lens of vapor that
doesn't have anywhere to go it can't go
condensate and rain right and so it's
stuck there it's not like we are running
out of water our planet has just as much
water right right but our land is
running out of water yeah that's
interesting that's really interesting
and actually
um you pointed something out I'm a
little embarrassed that I didn't know
this also right so I've been uh since
you're a rather intimidating figure to
bring anything in this realm to and so
I'm kind of pleased no no it's it's good
I I'm always delighted by people who
know stuff deeply enough to just deliver
important facts that you've somehow been
overlooking yeah
um I picked up the Habit from my uh
grandfather who was
um
my earliest scientific mentor of you
know being glued to the window of the
aircraft when you fly anyway because
there's so much to see right it's
troubling for us with long legs because
we both want the aisle and the window
seat and yeah I have not been in that
predicament but uh
it's it's it sounds tragic frankly
um yeah I would just uh you know take
the window and that's what I do with the
social cost of stuff tingling for the
next 12 hours but you know get out the
window exactly but anyway
um so you know what has been out the
window has changed in my lifetime a lot
along with a bunch of other things
um one of the things that has
proliferated uh to insane proportions
are these circular uh Fields yeah
um yeah pivots pivots you call them yep
can you describe what a pivot is so
pivot is where you have a well
in a spot where potentially you can grow
something
and where the water then comes out it
pivots into a long pipe that swim swings
on a uh around the axis and you you get
more or less a wheel as this pipe swings
around and there's sprinklers attached
to the whole thing so you've got an
irrigation an elevated irrigation array
yeah on Wheels yep that is moving around
a circular and basically the idea is
it's kind of an automated
self-irrigating totally you can control
them with smartphones yeah oh yeah
cool I guess that would make sense you
know but you mix fertilizer in and it
just distributes it at whatever
proportions
yeah yeah so the thing that I didn't
know I mean I knew that those were crops
and I knew that they were irrigated I
didn't realize I should have realized
because obviously that's an irrigation
that circle is an irrigation
um scar effectively
um but that every one of those is a well
suggests something
um profound about the level to which
this activity is you know unless
somebody has paid direct attention to
the equilibrium that the aquifer that
they are tapped into is being recharged
at the same rate as being depleted you
know or better
then that is a short-term process it's a
short-term process yeah short-term
process and at the same time what you've
got is all of this habitat that was by
definition involved in some sort of
ecological equilibrium with respect to
nutrients right you are now extracting
you are taking off that land whatever it
is that is being grown there and so you
know no kidding that we have a topsoil
crisis and a aquifer depletion crisis
and the problem uh
is in the style of thinking that doesn't
look backward enough to understand oh
all of that wealth was loaded into these
places by processes like beavers that
you then turned into hats right and you
are now uh
not only interrupting the process that
would cause the rain to fall at a rate
that would keep your equilibrium where
it was but you're depleting the stored
water beneath right and we're
withdrawing and we're not making
deposits right right we're on a we're on
a spending spree that we haven't noticed
and and right you know part of what
you're telling me is that what we are
spending is Downstream of a process
called beavering right and
to the extent that that is known I don't
think it's well understood by most
people who are looking out the window of
the plane or making decisions about
farming and productivity or food
security or whatever they're thinking
about I I think this just does not it
hasn't reached the public well so that
gets to the
a decision being made as an individual
versus something that's in the interest
of the public at large right if you're
if you're a farmer and you're irrigating
crops and you're feeding people but yeah
the water's coming out of somewhere that
I don't fully understand and it's
getting lower every year
um
do you take a hit and stop farming
because
you know that you acknowledge that that
is a
not a long-term solution or do you keep
farming and hope that something else
happens in the broader world I mean I
think that's where we get into kind of I
forget what you called it you had
something you'd talk about in class uh
the more Paradox
or something tragedy of the commons
Collective action problems okay so you
know there's a lot of ways to describe
it but what you're getting at is that we
have a collective interest in not
um
liquidating the well-being introduced to
the landscape by beavers we have a
collective interest and a lineage level
interest right right our descendants
five generations from now to depend on
the fact that we will not have ignored
the equilibrium factor and just depleted
at the highest rate possible and then
assumed that some process would
magically rescue us at the end of that
yep right those processes sometimes do
rescue us and sometimes they don't and
we can't afford the ones that don't
um but but anyway the the point is and
this is one of these really important
places where there is a discussion that
absolutely has to take place between
um what I would call a hard-headed
progressives and I don't want to presume
to Define you but I believe you are a
hard-headed progressivism I
and so-called conservatives and what I
hope will happen is that the
conservatives of whom
there are many who are frankly
struggling to preserve the gains that 10
years ago we all agreed were good right
struggling to preserve you know a fair
colorblind Society
um in which everyone has access to the
market and you know a means to get ahead
in which you know Merit produces Rewards
conservatives who are doing that job
are
I now find them
strangely deaf to the idea that being a
conservative also naturally requires us
to preserve the substrate on which we
all live right that the society that
does you know reward hard work and
insight and doesn't give a damn what
color your skin is or what your sexual
orientation is or any of those other
parameters that Society
only works if the underlying stuff
continues to exist for us to to utilize
and in some sense what I'm getting at is
I believe that sustainability is a
natural concept that conservatives
should embrace but because of
uh
the dialogue about ecology having
focused so heavily on global warming and
because there are clearly things wrong
with the portrayal of global warming I
don't know I assume you're not a dark
horse uh listener but you know Heather
and I have navigated this a bunch of
times right we are believe that global
warming is real but we also believe that
we are being given a story that's far
too
um
black and white to be realistic that it
does have a high PR budget yeah it has a
very high PR budget and by conservative
neighbors would point out gives them a
certain amount of skepticism it is a
very good reason for skepticism and the
fact that we know from inside the
academy at any time people are in a
panic over some process that is
threatening them the chances that the
literature represents an accurate
exploration of the factors that go in
One Direction or the other is
effectively zero right so you know I
think the point is
the models a models are not the same
thing as empirical results and we are
treating those models as empirical
results
and those models models are always
suspect because you can if you are
willing to put enough parameters into a
model you can get it to match any
Behavior you want it doesn't mean that
you've identified something real right
it becomes just a self-fulfilling uh
generator of academic papers but so if
we put aside that we know that there's
something wrong with the discussion
about global warming and that that's
dangerous and tragic because we do need
to know what the truth of it is right
um but just put aside global warming the
point is we've got an environmental
crisis that has nothing to do with
global warming global warming we're a
complete fiction we would still be in a
very dangerous circumstance because of
Collective action questions in Game
Theory because of failure to recognize
equilibria and you know those things
require good governance to solve them
and this is you know this is the bitter
pill I think for uh libertarianism right
I have some sympathy with Libertarians
because I believe they have identified
the central value that we should be
maximizing right realized Liberty is a
great value to maximize precisely
because it forces you to solve every
other issue right you know you can't you
can't be free if you are in danger of
being wiped out by a medical crisis in
your family right so if we really tried
to maximize how much Liberty individuals
could act could uh could actually
exercise then we would have to solve all
of these problems and good governance is
required of course at the moment
I don't think anybody who's looking at
what our governments are doing can be
all that enthusiastic about empowering
them right so anyway I've again led us
for our field but
um well I think there's an interesting
thing here and that
um
if we focus on carbon
it's kind of hard to wrap your mind
around especially when it's in the air
it's invisible yep you know non-toxic
can't see it doesn't smell maybe uh
maybe something technological will save
us yeah right but until then there's not
much anybody can do uh with the typical
toolkit yep whereas if you're thinking
about the water cycle and you're
thinking about this complex system
there's a lot that each individual human
can do
to facilitate a shift I mean it becomes
a land use conversation right and
um
you know it's interesting what I have a
lot of friends who are are very
conservative and they uh
they have a
um a deeper relation to the land if I'm
going to paint with a broad brush that a
lot of my friends who are much more
Progressive right in fact usually the
folks who know the most about Beaver are
the beaver Trappers that are being
demonized then by the folks who are
trying to save the beaver right and yet
these uh these folks know more about
beavers than a lot of the folks who are
raising money for Beaver projects right
um but I wonder if there's something
with the Baseline you know the Baseline
that conservatives are are feeling
protective of
um doesn't extend far enough back
to prior to when we started
the extractive process that is
um
you know not going to go too long in the
future like like there's something
that's invisible back there when beavers
were in charge of water
for all of North America
and and
we the conservation tendency the current
conservative tendency to like hey let's
stabilize this system where it's at and
just change when we see it necessary
um I don't think it's it sees that I
mean this was the case when we came in
and uh made national parks right the
Yosemite is the perfect example where
there's these huge beautiful Meadows and
these you know towering trees and and
there was the conservatives at the time
were like there's just this one problem
there's these people who live here right
you know and I I encountered this with
some of the work I did with you and
Heather when we were in Panama too like
this tendency to be like well let's just
get the people out and then this
beautiful thing will be retained all
right the awanichi yeah the Indians who
were yeah now what does that Valley look
like well is it fully encroached in
Brush you know all those flowers that
were the first foods that people were
maintaining are diminished and you
realize that was another because system
the engineer that we took off the
landscape people were in charge of
Justice beavers have been methodically
managing
the waterways right people were
methodically managing the Uplands with
fire so so we see these collapses right
but but the conservation tendency
was blind to the process applying to the
people who are maintaining a productive
system with fire or that beavers were
maintaining a productive system with
water
so I don't know I agree with your
diagnosis there's a you know there's a
willingness to look back a certain
distance but not far enough to really
understand that you know you have
stepped into a new realm and you're
you're failing to you know whether
you're a conservative or a progressive
or whatever you are you're failing to
preserve this thing of value and
my sense is that people are basically
alike in that they
appreciate
um
beautiful places they appreciate uh
things that don't require intensive work
to maintain right give people the
opportunity and everybody looks you know
at a gorgeous landscape and has
a positive feeling about it right right
what
what I don't what I don't know what to
do about is
we start doing something at a small
scale inherently that's how everything
starts and when you are at that small
scale the fact that that process if you
were to extrapolate up to some you know
immense inflation of that same process
then becomes a threat to your very
ability to persist
at what point does it make sense to have
that conversation right does it make
sense to have that conversation when
you're experimenting you know on the
workbench in your garage with that
little process that if it really caught
on a hundred years later would be an
issue no right you should be allowed to
experiment but the
there is no way that functioning at the
scale that we are at that the right
answer to the question doesn't involve
okay
in what way can we rationally rain
ourselves in without triggering any of
the failure modes right well if we rain
ourselves in and our competitors Don't
Rain themselves in the place gets
destroyed anyway and we will also have
lost out and they will be more powerful
than we classic tragedy of the commons
that's a problem you have to solve right
you you cannot do this as a matter of
personal responsibility you cannot do
this with your nation behaving
responsibly and others not behaving
responsibly it has to be done as a
matter of some kind of good governance
and I don't know how you would do it at
the moment I'm absolutely terrified if
governments having more power because I
think they're all malignant I don't know
of a government that I trust at the
moment but you know I also don't want to
die of that concern because it means
well we're not going to manage any of
the things that have to be managed in
order for us to persist so doesn't that
seem like a a natural place where
conservatives and progressives
ought to be talking at this moment about
how can we keep doing you know how can
we continue to have the goose that lays
the golden eggs without destroying the
world on which it lives yeah yeah and
and what I found doing the work that I
do is it it is uniting
for folks like as long as it can not
become a fuzzy animal that needs saved
issue if we can stick to
Beaver our process this is intelligent
complex thing that we need to defer to
we need to put the professionals back in
charge of our water
because what we've been doing with the
water doesn't seem to be working very
well right
um that's something that I found
consistently everyone can get on board
with but then you start saying well
on your land
you now have to make a concession you
have to take those three acres out of
productivity and allow beavers to return
it to Wetland and that's where things
get edgy because people are making
livelihoods off this land right and it's
like why would I incur the cost to
society Society values a system that's
working better and Society values Beaver
but
and then I am as a landowner going to
incur the cost of that you know what's
in it for me right now actually
um this raises
I don't want to pretend to know more
about it than I do but there was an
episode in uh in Ecuador
where Ecuador under President Correa
made a point that I thought was exactly
accurate so Ecuador has the world's most
diverse habitat in it in yasuni in the
Amazon
and there is oil
inyasuni
and Korea basically said to the
International Community
this is a treasure it should not be
destroyed over the temporary extraction
of oil
but that is not the responsibility of
the Ecuadorian people this is a treasure
of planet Earth
and what we need is
the resources so that the people of
Ecuador are not punished for preserving
This Global treasure and then we will
not extract the oil
and the world stared him down it said no
and my sense is game theoretically
he was perfectly right
this is exactly the problem with all of
these things right just because Yosemite
happens to be in your backyard doesn't
give you the right to destroy it yeah
right same with yasuni same with any of
these things do we have the right if we
want to screw up all of the aquifers in
North America to let all of the topsoil
wash into the sea you know to you know
use fossil fuels to inject the systems
with you know non-biotic nitrogen not
really right why does any generation get
the right to screw up the planet and
leave a lesser place for future
Generations that just seems to me that
we have a moral obligation we're never
going to be perfect at it we're always
going to destroy some stuff we don't
mean to
but in principle no generation has the
right to leave a lesser planet to Future
generations and you know the idea that
well we'll think of something
sometimes you do but then you know
Extinction is a one-way process right we
are going to lose creatures that will
not you know future generate you know
it's like the the
Tasmanian wolf it's gone it's one
example but yeah
um but that was something that was part
of the richness of Earth and it's no
longer and
um
in any case I do hope that uh
that conservatives will begin to
recognize you know I sometimes hear and
it frightens me that modern
conservatives you know I I say this
provocative thing which I I mostly
believe can you say provocative things
sometimes sometimes I say uh
conservatives defend the gains of past
liberals right
um which is mostly true maybe it's
entirely true if we think broadly enough
about it but anyway it's somewhere in
the ballpark uh and the what comes back
lately is you know
progressives have done their job it's
over right this is now the time for us
to conserve what has been achieved and
it's not like I don't know what they're
talking about I do on the other hand
it's not achieved because you can't
continue to do what we're doing
indefinitely which means that you know
you've got a system which is going to
destroy itself for all of its failure to
pay heed to those equilibria
and it is going to inherently leave a
more boring more uh
a a depleted Planet a fewer worse
opportunities that is just simply Less
Pleasant to be human on and it's it's
not our right to do it and I think
um
I hope that conservatives will
understand that there is still something
that they have to partner with
hard-headed progressives about because
we've got problems we haven't solved yet
which is
how do you how do you do good governance
without it becoming captured and being
malignant right or failing to protect
the things that future Generations are
entitled to have yeah yeah well and
that's where as a progressive
um
we get a lot of ideas and we need the
conservatives to help rein Us in 100
because we like those ideas you don't
want to unleash the the progressives
without the constraints somebody's
saying we need the leash you need
somebody something that pays attention
to the unintended consequences of your
you know your Solutions because they are
they're always there but
conversely there needs to be somebody
who's saying hey
this doesn't look like it's working out
we need to shift
you know right and uh so that's that's
what I guess we find ourselves doing I'm
curious
um
to put on your game theory hat
if we were to
try to make
not even make it see I'm talking like a
progressive we're gonna make something
um
a system where
individuals weren't penalized for
turning back over control of the
landscape to Beavers especially in these
areas where historically beavers have
maintained this system that we have a
lot of interest in seeing into the
future
um
how could that look in a in a resilient
game theoretically resilient
um way
you know how how can we how can we
create
something and it's going to involve
governance right because there needs to
be some like larger party that's that's
putting forth a program yep um
but where people who are stewards of
land and trying to make a living off of
land are penalized for
um turning over that land to a rodent
Steward right right now and you know
as somebody who owns a little bit of
land I get it right sure the last thing
you want is you you buy some piece of
land and you've got some idea for it and
then suddenly a sacred animal shows up
and starts uh moving stuff around and
you're not allowed you know your piece
of land's value just radically shifted
on you right and yeah and there's
regulations that come in if that Wetland
becomes a wetland of an official Sense
on the county you know right yeah no
you're you're praying for you know not
no beavers in my backyard yeah
I get it
um on the other hand
I think the problem is you've got to get
the pieces of the puzzle that are
disjointed to meat right if we all like
the kind of world that uh highly active
Beaver population produces but we none
of us want to pay the price of uh
keeping that thing functioning
um then you know there's a natural
interaction of those two things which is
that there's a small price to be paid
um and my my biggest concern about it is
how do you discover
what you know we're not going to turn
North America back over to the Beavers
it's not going to happen but it doesn't
mean that you couldn't figure out well
how much you know where can we
effectively allow this activity to
um
uh to take on its uh its full scale and
where can't we afford not to have it I
mean one of the things we haven't even
talked about yet it's not just this
water cycle but it's all sorts of other
things that preoccupy us like fire yeah
yeah all the all of our preoccupations
you know fire water security
carbon sequestration I mean you've got
anaerobic Wetlands sequestering carbon
yeah these are all things we're spending
billions of dollars on yeah and I spent
almost a decade running a restoration
program where I spent a lot of money
um and you know I was I was doing these
projects and the and the way that
everyone's putting these projects out
you know we're gonna we're gonna save
salmon and and there's a bit of a
reckoning right now because it doesn't
seem to be working
um we're spending money but it's not
working and then and then over you know
nobody's paying attention to a little
piece of land and a beaver starts doing
its thing and pretty soon you have a
system that I can't build with a million
dollars of restoration funds right you
know and it my projects don't hold a
candle to that
yeah it's it's uh but they did it for
free
right they did it for free because it
was in their interest to just do it yeah
um and you know increasingly I mean this
is the lesson of biology right when
Heather and I say welcome to complex
systems
that is us effectively needling people
for failing to understand that you know
again and again they walk into a complex
system and they think they understand it
and they think they're going to improve
it and they you know in the end are
scratching their head well that that
should have worked and it's like no it
shouldn't have worked you didn't
understand a fraction of what you needed
to understand to make this happen you
know presumably the Beavers don't
understand it in conscious terms either
but they Intuit how you interact with
these systems and
um so anyway the punchline to almost all
of these puzzles
is the lighter handed your intervention
is the better right yeah and you know
this is a and can you successfully
kick something off that's an evolved
complex system where you can stand back
and say
my work here is done you know what's the
little push that gets right because in
habitat Restoration World we've uh kind
of fallen into a little bit of a trap
maybe set for ourselves by doing too
much ecology where we you know measure
things and we then describe an ecosystem
based on what we've measured you know
this many stems of this species this
many stems of this species and
um a lot of the Restoration World is
caught up in then you know well here's
what a reference site that I mean that's
the term right a reference site looks
like and so then I'm gonna go build an
analogous site over here you know it
might be a cattle pasture right now but
I've got Tonka toys that burn diesel and
big budget and
um and then what happens is we build
these
artifices you know we build what we
think would look like habitat but we've
we haven't keyed into Beaver as a verb
or whatever the underlying process is
that actually resulted in that habitat
you know habitat is the product of a
bunch of process that consistently Works
upon a system and so we go build
something that looks like it and it
looks like it for one or two years and
then it starts falling apart because
Avenger being like there's nothing
maintaining that right
um and that's that's a huge blind spot
and the way we've been going about
fixing things
um it's not what can we do to turn a
complex evolve system on again
it's well how can we construct this idea
of beautiful and healthy
yeah I mean it that's such a tragic
tragic story because
you know once or twice and then you
ought to begin to realize what you're
doing wrong which is assuming that you
know the proxies that you are using to
indicate what's taking place in one of
these habitats are not the sum total of
the story and the number of things
that have to work together is large and
the chances that you've missed one are
near certain
at least one and the thing about you
know whatever the beaver is it intuits
these things right I mean if you compare
just in your mind you know the
um the guy with the excavator
and his intuition about exactly how
where and in you know in what fashion to
dig versus this animal with millions of
years of built up experience that causes
it to Intuit these things
there's no comparison and you know
what's more the dude with the excavator
goes home at night right the beaver's
there and presumably there's a feedback
where the beaver understands something
about what it tried to do didn't quite
work and it needs a little and you know
it's it's it's a
I mean really in some sense you captured
It Beaver is a process right it is an
animal but it's also a process and that
process is way better than anything that
you're going to be able to to describe
in a publication and you know deploy and
you know get a crew of people to to
bring into the world it just doesn't
work that way right yeah I mean our
Publications are useful and that we can
go into the beaver wetlands and we can
say hey look it actually is sequestering
carbon or yep you know hey look there
actually is a massive amount of insects
here where we don't see insects
elsewhere you know or we we can take the
constituent parts and admire them
um it seems to me an excellent tool for
evaluating how effective something is it
does not strike me as particularly
likely to describe what you should do
exacting habitats you know you're
talking about
you're talking about Aesthetics you're
talking about better zoos you're not
talking about a habitat that works and
you know it's the the biosphere project
also tells the story because you would
think
you would think it is possible to
enclose a space and make a system that
is self-sustaining you can make it
simple enough you can load anything in
it that you want you can put highly
intelligent people there to troubleshoot
no right it doesn't work yeah it's not
to say it's impossible of course it's
possible but it's way harder than you
think it is yeah right yep I'm reminded
too of this uh
I think it's one of the great cautionary
tales which nobody seems to to know but
there's this animal in in Madagascar
called the injury you know it no I'm one
of the nobody seems to know well it's a
it's it's the most marvelous creature in
some ways it's very surprising
um it looks like a big teddy bear right
it's got big teddy bear ears has kind of
a teddy bear face and that's a large
animal like I don't know it must be
60 pounds something like this it's a
lemured it's not a true lemur but it's
in that uh lives in trees yep yep
monogamous
uh locomotes by vertical grasping and
leaping so it holds onto a tree and then
it flings its arms nice and lands in the
next tree and bounces from One Tree to
the next amazing creature and to cap it
all off the call of this thing
is like humpback whale right like
imagine a humpback whale call in a
forest it's just a totally marvelous
very surprising creature
it's a full over eats leaves
eats a lot of different kinds of leaves
why because they're toxic yeah right and
so you can't spread that around yeah you
want to deal with a bunch of different
toxins at low levels rather than any
heavy dose of any one toxin but here's
the thing this animal would be a slam
dunk winner in any zoo in the world that
could happen
it's never been successfully kept in
captivity right you can't do it there's
no way that you can get a diet varied
enough even worse okay they have
literally tried to just
put a limit on a piece of habitat that
it's already in right just put a fence
around something big enough that the
animal is just technically in captivity
it dies well we just don't know enough
right yeah so something we're missing
there's something we're missing and
um and I think the point is
all of these puzzles are like this we
have to realize how early in the story
of biology we are right we're just
getting our bearings and yeah we know a
lot and it's impressive but it you know
the degree to which we know a lot is
nothing compared to the degree to which
it is complex right right and
um
anyway the uh
yeah I mean there's just in in thinking
about Beaver Wetlands there's just
little hints of some of the
if you imagine all of the animals that
were reliant on that predictable
version of habitat beavers managing
habitat for thousands of years for
example trumpeter swan seemed to
specialize on nesting specifically on
Beaver lodges really yeah and you read
accounts of you know trumpeter swans
were ubiquitous as a topping for the
Beaver Lodge right which makes sense
it's a beautiful place to put a nest
right
um protected protected and you've got a
boat around you yeah got an alarm system
an alarm system yeah that Beaver is
going to be out there slapping that's
tail if it sees anything in the
underground sure yeah
yeah
um and just just kind of
realizing there's a whole world of
um
other forms of life that are reliant on
this predictable system and we're not
going to understand all of them so let's
go we're not going to do an exhaustive
list but what are what are the kinds of
creatures you're thinking of Beyond
trumpeter swans okay so you've got a
couple things that are less visible the
Beavers are doing or maybe not less
visible but we don't think about them as
much right so one of the things that we
all look at is the Beaver Dam and it's
spreading out water laterally across the
landscape
they're also moving literally tons of
vegetation
from outside the stream system into the
stream system right we've got this nerdy
term in biology a lock thinness right
lock thinness inputs it's like from
one's space out down into another so so
you've got a system where
um this rodent is probably driving much
of the food web
within the stream
um right because it's enriching this
yeah enriching the stream I mean we
think about like fall leaves yep right
but this this animal is churning
vegetation into the stream and in fact
folks who are snorkeling for looking for
you know juvenile fish often refer to
these collections of chewed on Beaver
sticks as River reefs because you
snorkel up to them it's all fish
eyeballs staring out
at you it's this aggregation you know
and all the little inverts are there and
then the fish and it's cover and so
there's I mean that's one example of
just like something that's kind of a bit
like that yeah feeling sticks and that
um that suggests a whole other process
too because one of the weird things
about salmon
is
they make no sense in the streams that
they're in they're not a stream creature
they're an ocean creature which is
breeding in these streams right and
you know you could it's obvious when you
watch them go upstream and they're like
you know too tall to fit in some little
section of this stream like this is a
giant ocean predatory fish you know
breeding in this riparian habitat and
then dying but the thing is okay well
what does that do
this thing is effectively Fanning out
into the Pacific right collecting Marine
Resources in huge numbers dragging them
Against Gravity up a mountain and then
leaving them yep right that's
that is a powerful process right that is
nutrients going uphill to enrich those
ecosystems and now you're telling me
that beavers are having this important
um encouraging effect on that process
yeah and I mean if you're a fish it
really only makes sense to go through
all that expensive that's right I forget
sometimes it's hard to remember but I
think I'm a fish too you are you are
definitely a fish um
well if you're a fish that specializes
in hauling your carcass up before
depositing it uh
you'd want to do that if the habitat
you're putting your Offspring in ensures
like it's really good right yeah it
ensures success and so having a
obsessive rodent that's like come
summertime there's gonna be water here
right you know and I'm feeding the
bottom of the food web yeah you know and
I'm creating water and there's food for
all the the little fry yeah no it's you
can see how all these things the fish
going up the stream doesn't make sense
when it's standing out of the water yeah
but that's a stream that's degraded down
into a ditch too oh true you know so so
we even with watching salmon go up and
you're like why did why you know they're
they're spawning often across the
Pacific or the west and it
incredibly degraded landscape yeah you
know and if you look at even like the
Oregon coast Coho the main thing that's
highlighted as well we could probably
get it off the endangered species left
if
juvenile rearing habitat so where the
little ones grow up yeah and the one
thing they point to is well we need more
beaver dams if you know so I think the
answer to your earlier question then is
in part
if people understood I mean I don't know
that this connection makes sense but
you're talking about the alteration of
weather based on the distribution of
water heavily affected by
um Beaver activity
so did the skiers know that the depth of
snow and the quality of the snow that
they're interacting with is affected by
you know beavers I don't know that it is
but probably it is at least somewhat
maybe it's a lot do you know the sport
fisherman right who are fishing for
salmon out you know in the sea do they
know that the you know that their
success rate is dependent on beavers you
know Upland beavers probably if they do
only you know only a couple yeah so the
question is
do people drinking water right you know
no right water which has
turned so terrible in my lifetime right
water almost everywhere is
kind of gross to drink and it's amazing
that wasn't true that's why I hide in
the Hills right mainly where the water
in good water yeah no it was it's a it's
a big deal it's a huge people are
drinking water that's compromised
heavily compromised and to the point of
being distasteful it's not even Trace
Amounts it's significantly what's your
body saying go find other water other
water yeah this is not true this is
water if you're if you're dying of
thirst
um
and you know beaver dams that's another
thing we didn't talk about but you've
got sediment accumulating behind beaver
dams well that leads to cleaner water
right sure you've got the filter filter
system built in and and a lot of things
that you know cities are struggling with
is one clean water and two as you cover
soil with asphalt and concrete and
buildings then when you get a delusion
of rain yep it all runs off really
really quickly yeah sweeping a lot of
the crud from Humanity yeah you know and
so we have these huge pulses of water
through the systems that are still
streams right it goes way up and then it
slacks away so then it erodes without
soaking in yep yeah yeah and so you have
both a problem with uh you know the
water being dirty but then you also have
a problem with like too much at once and
so what do you have Beaver Dam well you
have a filter and a speed bump
and so you've got enough of those speed
bumps and you increase the residency
time of the flood yeah too right so
these catastrophic things where then you
see Downstream towns getting
just Havoc being wreaked Yeah by these
floods well if you had more speed bumps
higher in the system that would be
retaining some of that sediment that's
moving you know cleaning the water up
um but also increasing the residence
time before it's just this charging
torrent charging torrent that washes off
uselessly into the sea yeah yeah it
washes our soil and our water yeah yeah
oh man that's really powerful
I will tell you years ago there was a I
don't remember if you and I ever went to
it together but
there was a a beaver Wetland near
Evergreen
I explored that Wetland yeah yeah at the
moment I'm not remembering its name do
you no grass Lakes no no
uh there was a there was a couple beaver
dams just near campus and in fact the
first Beaver that I saw in the wild yeah
I was waiting for the 41 bus at red
square and this Beaver wanders out of
the slough
she's supposed to do in there I don't
know they like wandered over to the
smokers
everyone stopped and the bus was late
and uh I kicked myself for not like
getting out and going and following it
right I don't know what I was up to what
was it out yeah it just then wandered
back into the slough and that was my
first Beaver sighting yeah yeah that's
good but yeah Evergreen had beavers so
yeah they were presumably still does
definitely beavers in the habitat and
then this one place
which I think I'm embarrassed to say I'm
not sure that when I first started going
there that I knew that it was Beaver
created it was a large body of water
and at some point I figured out it was a
a beaver created body of water and I
started exploring the dam and it was a
huge structure you know I had entire
classes walk out onto this thing and
stand there to talk about
um beavers and their implication and you
know extended phenotype and whatever
else but I remember one year
uh I think it was particularly heavy
rainfall and the Beaver Dam burst oh
yeah yeah and it was crazy it was just
the thing like emptied and it didn't
empty all the way it emptied down to a
much lower height than it had been
and then so I you know of course had the
biologists overreaction to this that
this was like the end of that habitat
yeah
you know because you know beavers what
they did was they
fix the damn thing yep and it filled
right back up and uh so what this leads
me to wonder is that dam is
anti-fragile it's bound you know every
weak spot is the place where it's going
to burst and those beavers are
presumably not putting it back just the
way it was but
I mean building it in such a way that it
is probably growing stronger over time
and so yeah the dams that are most
likely to fail are the new ones oh is
that right yeah it makes good sense so
then what you're also describing is a
self-assembling self upgrading filter
system right if you're talking about a
sequence of beaver habitats that are you
know dampening that pulse of water
filtering the water as it comes through
slowing it down so it's able to soak
into these habitats making them richer
and wetter habitats right that's a
process that gets better over time and
um
I mean I guess
I don't I there's a part of me that
doesn't want to introduce
Tech here at all but just as an analogy
imagine imagine an Elon Musk right had a
secret robot project in which he had uh
these little robots which were going to
terraform some landscape obviously being
prepared for a trip to Mars where they
were going to improve Landscapes over
time and make them hospitable to a
series of creatures that would then be
you know introduced we'd think this was
you know incredibly marvelous technology
yeah but here it is it's happened on its
own completely we all know the name of
the thing most of us do not understand
how profound its impact on North America
has been
and uh
um and we
because we don't understand what it has
produced because every time we see a
flat bottomed you know fertile Valley we
don't think that is the work of past
beavers that I am looking at we don't
really we don't know enough to lament
the fact that the Beavers aren't there
and therefore that there's a clock
ticking it's not going to last yeah that
for that fertility right there's a clock
ticking there's a clock ticking yeah and
so
I think the answer to the question that
you asked is somehow we've got to close
the logical loops on this system so the
point is
again I don't know if skiing is a good
example of something that's benefited
but it at least would work in that
direction you like skiing
think about the beavers and they're
rolling it I know that sounds crazy but
it's not right right you like salmon
here's the rule that they're playing
there right you know do you like
affordable food right well here's the in
the Mars context people would get it
yeah right you like living on Mars well
you still need these robots doing the
thing that's maintaining the system of
life support
right that's the thing if you did this
on Mars the point is you know if you
don't know what an equilibrium is you're
fired right because that's fatal yeah
right you need to know anytime you're
intervening in a system where you're
depleting something you're enter you're
interfering with an equilibrium and
those equilibria are necessary for life
and the point is that's what we're doing
but nobody's fired for not knowing what
a equilibrium is right right and right
um
it is not
uh unpredictable where that ends right
that ends with us scratching our heads
at how so many things that were once
Grand are no longer functional and you
know
it's totally needless which is what
we're doing already but it's only going
to get more pronounced it's only going
to get more pronounced and you know
you're flying over
the landscape looking at the opposite of
beavers right those what you call them
yeah the pivots pivots my mom had a good
analogy she's like we were talking about
it and it's like uh looking at mosquito
welts you know you're you're sucking
this life force out of the landscape and
it's causing this inflammation yeah this
little circular welt right and that's
productive for us right now we're
growing food there but you can only have
so many mosquitoes
right right yeah and there's a point at
which there's no there's no more lymph
there yeah and uh yeah yeah well I um
I hope we can close some of those
circles so that um
people you know I I think you know what
what I hope people will get from this
discussion
is that a topic that probably most
people thought they had no interest in
turns out to have a thousand fascinating
and even if you're not fascinated by
them important facets right right
um right you know fire suppression is
not a small matter here in the west this
is a serious issue that we deal with the
smoke that comes off these fires even
when the fires are remote the
degradation and the quality of life you
know as a result of
a failure to understand equilibria with
respect to um
the natural process of fire that you
know removes the fuel at a particular
rate where you know we had what a
hundred years of fire suppression that
resulted in a huge buildup of fuel so
that when the fires burn they decimate
the landscape right that's a failure to
understand equilibria and what I learned
from you is that actually beavers are
also uh an important factor in
suppressing Fire by
adjusting the way water flows through
these ecosystems so you know
are you interested in fire suppression
in the west well if you live in the west
you better be right because you're going
to be breathing the consequences
otherwise or driven out of your home or
whatever so so anything more to say
about um beavers and Fire
uh I had the experience of um
responding sorry volunteer with search
and rescue and I responded to a fire I
guess it's two years ago now that burnt
two of the nearby towns down more or
less Phoenix and talent and there's a
green way that connects all of these
towns in the Rogue Valley
um you know a really great thing right
somebody said hey we want a Greenway
let's buffer the creek let's give it a
lot of room let's put a bike path in
yeah I believe I've ridden repeatedly
down there when I when Heather uh got me
a bike building course in uh
yeah yeah of course um I used to ride
that Greenway all the time yeah before
the fire before the fire go ahead what
happened yeah so so we had some intense
wins and somebody started a little fire
that became a big fire
um that Greenway which to our human
perspective looked like verdant healthy
habitat acted like WIC and it it drew
fire
through two cities
wow you know when we imagine Fire coming
in from the hills and like time to
escape this way but no this was it never
even went into the hills it drew fire
through these cities because the stream
had collapsed down into a ditch the
water was unavailable it was down there
right and people got used to that it's
like a creek you know something you look
down on right and and even in that
context where we had a really wide space
where people hadn't actually built close
to it the fact that the creek was
collapsed meant that
plants that can take advantage of this
novel Niche like Blackberry had fully
colonized this entire riparian area
right if if there was water that was all
over the place and there was this messy
braided marshy thing you know black boy
don't do well in that right and the
native plants they were lamenting the
loss of would be doing excellently well
because that's what they are used to
right but instead instead of having a
fire buffer instead of having something
that wouldn't burn
we had something that was extremely
explosive uh when it came to a spine it
was productive with exactly the wrong
exactly the wrong stuff yeah and so
um you know I I remember standing at a
roadblock that I was helping to maintain
at that point near the creek and uh you
could just hear like people's propane
tanks exploding and the the valley was
glowing and you know two towns burning
down puts off a lot of light
um
and yeah looking at their Creek and just
realizing wow this is what we've brought
um by allowing these systems to collapse
out allowing that soil to dry up these
novel niches where then we get this
dense vegetation
um you know it has consequences has huge
consequences and so the reverse is true
too with with beavers and fire where you
have a system where beavers are
maintaining a landscape that's wetted
you see wildlife run to that when
there's a fire a lot of folks that work
cattle will see their cattle go to the
beaver Wetlands when there's a fire on
the east side you know of Oregon or so
they've got to be two reasons for that I
would guess
um one the activity of the Beaver is
fire suppressive in nature but two
the choice of beavers to to alter a
particular piece of habitat may be
responsive to it being resilient to fire
because if you because remember the
other ecosystem engineer that's been
operating the same timeline
people were burning we're making making
use of fire yeah right so there was a
boundary between the two ecosystems
that's right that had to be maintained
that had to be maintained and you can
imagine let's say that you had a beaver
that was naive about fire
and it was very good at engineering and
it modified some habitat that was
particularly prone to Fire and the point
is well that's a short-term project too
right because to the extent that the
beaver is dependent on you know trees
and the riparian Zone
surviving then the point is it made an
error yeah building in a place that had
an Achilles heel so anyway yeah you
could uh you could see both of those
processes at work and you could see
augmentation right whereas again in the
west we have
a plague of eucalyptus trees right I
presume beavers do not utilize
eucalyptus I've never heard of it yeah
yeah although they will go after incense
Cedar which has a pretty
pungent uh it it does seem to be rare
though and they seem to mostly use it
for building things with and not eating
it yeah building with cedar mixes in an
aquatic setting right right totally
exactly well the interesting thing is
too in the context of fire if you have a
degraded system that don't doesn't have
beavers
uh maybe it's super incised and so they
can't every time they try to build a dam
it can't persist because the velocity is
just too much it's like a bowling alley
yeah of water every winter and it blows
beaver dams out which is the case with
Bear Creek for example for my from my
Valley
um
and that's usually because we've
straightened it or what have you but
that would happen naturally in some
systems too if something catastrophic
happened and you get this channelization
and
um well then
that's an especially fire prone
situation because beavers can't
maintain that and you do get a fire
that's a stand replacing fire well sand
replacing fires then you have a lot of
accumulated Woody debris that starts
crashing down in that stream
and your velocity barrier is suddenly
not such a thing anymore because you've
got all this roughness and Tangled
burned wood that starts catching the
sediment that comes off the fire because
you know sediment's moving one's a fire
fire landscape isn't late yeah it gets
rained on
um fires are a reset for a system that
beavers are hard to find hard to to
utilize to utilize and suddenly you've
got something where every single one of
the hardwoods is bouncing back with
fresh new shoots you've gotten rid of
the Conifer layer that you know beavers
don't really find palatable anyway and
all those are racked up in the Stream
and you've got you've hit reset and now
it's ready for beavers the tragic thing
is of course then what we usually do is
we go clean out every single stick that
falls in the creek because we're worried
about flooding implications and so it
only makes it worse
um oh my goodness but the the
intelligence of the system being what it
you know fires could be a good thing for
Beaver too and that they prep it prep a
habitat that's inaccessible to be more
accessible again
yeah that's interesting I I like that
concept of uh of reset and it is a kind
of a hopeful one right even a place that
isn't Beaver hospitable because the
velocity of the water is too high can as
a natural process can find itself within
range of you know Beaver architecture
that's cool we don't have to wait for
Wildfire we could go stick sticks in the
creek you know well I mean people do
yeah you you could you could encourage
the beavers in that way
um and presumably
my guess would be that the Beavers
actually detect the reset that the
consequences of fire might cause beavers
to go into Explorer mode
um because it may be possible that some
piece of habitat that wasn't useful is
now useful
um but presumably they are in Explorer
mode enough just by virtue of producing
Offspring uh yeah and it actually seems
like the adults themselves
go into Explorer mode every summer so
there's accounts dating back 150 years
of natural snow dancing but you know
like where did the Beavers go in July
and August
and it does appear that beavers will go
assess the surrounding landscape and
check in
and then they come back and they keep
investing or they don't you know so one
of the things we see happen on the
landscape sometimes is like
you know there's a nearby colony and it
gets trapped off and it's in better
habitat than this other colony while
they go into Explorer mode that summer
they find out hey those digs are open
yeah and then they jump ship on this one
and they move Downstream so what happens
then in the context of
some human who is having a disagreement
with Beaver at their driveway Culvert
you know the pipe where the water is
supposed to go through and beavers plug
it and they're like haha you know
that human left one hole in a perfectly
good Dam right
now now I've identified that I fixed the
issue we now have flooding
um
so people get on this treadmill of
trapping beavers crapping beaversed by
and they get replaced by other beavers
in the landscape who have identified no
that's the better habitat and so you
have a population sink you have a black
hole all right right so you can have
just one
depleting land that they are not
actually trying to keep beavers out of
exactly yeah yeah but because that was
the preferred habitat
then you're gonna see depletion and
probably because of that Explorer mode
yeah you know and and we've seen this
where
um you know a whole
little sub Watershed will be full of
beavers and then some land ownership
will change and the new landowner is
intolerant and they happen to be at the
best Beaver habitat and over the course
of the year they or two or five they
trap a lot of beavers and suddenly
there's no other beavers around
you know oh that's such a terrible story
yeah I mean it's also encouraging I
guess in that
usually folks don't want to be trapping
beavers right they're on that treadmill
and it's frustrating for them too so
kind of helping folks think through you
know can can the monkeys outsmart the
rodents generally you can or the fish
outsmart the fish right you know it
doesn't quite well
it's confusing yeah but but the promise
in doing that is like if you can
identify those populations things if you
can identify those black holes where
yeah where folks are struggling and you
know they may it's just a pest species
whatever it can have profound impacts on
the entire you know square miles of are
you talking about by getting them to
rethink getting rid of the Beavers or it
seems to me that if you could I mean
it's a weird thing to advocate for but
if they're going to be a black hole for
beavers through this process
getting them to reduce the quality of
that habitat that they're trying to keep
beavers out of so that other beavers
don't adopt it would also have that
effect it would yeah it would be
probably very illegal in most areas
really yeah because our wetlands are so
well protected legally
um that you can't purposely degrade a
wetland and that's part of the fear that
people feel when a beaver shows up it's
like
now I'm gonna have this animal that's
going to encumber my property with
additional regulation right you know
quick often before it starts doing stuff
yep
um yeah I get it yeah yeah but yes
that's true if you're if your property
was in a degraded state
um in comparison to other adjacent
properties then you could predict the
Beavers are going to occupy the next
best available habitat and what we often
see is if you have too many population
sinks
then beavers the only beavers you see
are the ones that are living on Rivers
because
Life is Peachy on a river man you can
have a bank Den right you've got all the
willow you could ever eat the water's
deep no need to build a dam yeah right
and
um as long as there's always room they
never hit carrying capacity right like
not all the spots are filled on the
river then no juveniles ever gonna have
to go make a living higher up in a
stream where you got to build a dam and
life is more work and water is scarce
um and so that you know people will say
well we have enough beavers they're in
all these systems but we're living in a
uh I've heard the term like functionally
extirpated right yeah and that yes
there's beavers but functionally right
they're no longer a verb so my guess
based on what you've said is that the
river beavers are present but they are
not as valuable that the work that they
do is not in a position to to have this
fire suppressive right they're not
managing water yeah they're not they're
cycling nutrients still sure you know
but it's we selfishly as people looking
at this we need it to be at the point
where the river's so chock-a-block full
of beavers that the young ones are
forced to go out and do real work do
some work yeah yeah right right yeah
that's uh interesting and and uh
quite quite sad really it's interesting
that it's the same animal that can do
this on a river and
um and managing Upland habitat yeah well
and that's cool too right because you
can take a a river beaver and go stick
it up Linda it's like damn it it does
exactly that it does a thing which
actually makes sense if you think about
it because you probably have a
you know a population level phenomenon
where the rivers are the thing that
links all of these disjointed Upland
habitats and so you know I'd be really
interesting to know maybe you do know
what the relationship is between the
river populations and all of these
little uh tributaries in the Hills yeah
no I don't there's been some genetic
studies done and basically it says
you know beavers are more related and
um watersheds and than they are in the
next Watershed over you know but it
didn't really tell that's not surprising
yeah exactly
um
is anything known about how many
generations a particular you know a
large Dam and Lodge represent how long a
particular lineage of beavers will
manage a particular piece of habitat
well it's kind of like the big whales
right we went killed them all and then
we're looking back at historical records
and we're like that whale was way bigger
than anything we see now how old was it
right no idea you know is that bowhead
whale that they found a 200 year old
Stone Point in yeah they're like okay
well we know they get to 200 yep right
um we're in a similar position with
Beaver because where are the places that
we didn't go trap out beavers and bus
beaver dams there's one spot in the
Boreal forest where there's a beaver dam
you can see from space
that's clearly been there a long time
wow and it's shifted so much of the
landscape that it's a it's a spot you
can identify
um
but yeah these I the the
life cycle of a beaver dam in a place
where there's a lot of sedimentation
right where the where the water turns
murky in the winter
um is that that will accumulate behind
the Beaver Dam and eventually you'll get
a meadow yep you know back to it being
flat because of beaver dams yep right
but the water has to go somewhere so
it'll be threaded through or maybe it'll
be over on this side now more than that
side and
um beavers will be building additional
dams and so it's this process of
um uplift right and I am creating land
creating land and so yeah those Cycles
are iterative where you'll have
you know
ghosts of beaver
kingdoms you know buried underneath the
New Meadows that have been formed more
recently right it's um
yeah so so a beaver dam that exists
for a really long time
uh as one Dam I would predict that
there's not a lot of sediment coming in
I guess is you know otherwise it would
have otherwise they're in settlement
yeah okay there's no reason these things
didn't last a really long time hundreds
of years yeah right or more and uh again
it's going to be compromised by the fact
that we're all we're looking at modern
stuff and we don't necessarily know what
the the pre pre-columbian or maybe even
pre-human uh situation was yeah and in a
beaver dam that's old even 20 years old
you can't tell it's a beaver dam right I
mean that's the that's the great yeah
that's right the classic like oh lattice
work of sticks that only lasts for two
or three years and then it looks like a
landscape right yeah yeah yeah they're
funny you have to identify them by the
fact that the water is behaving in a way
differently exactly exactly
um so what is the largest Beaver body of
water that is known oh I don't know I
don't know it's a good question and that
because there's you could measure that
two-way like tallest Beaver Dam right
right and you could measure laterally
out beavers when they when they so so
say you've got an in size system right
in size meaning that the creek has
collapsed into this trench yeah and
beavers successfully build a dam there
at first it kind of looks like the
Hoover Dam in a sense I mean it's just
this plug right
um but then quickly if they get out on
the on the valley floor they start
chasing the water with a release usually
pretty low Dam initially yeah and and
they are remarkably Adept at more or
less tracing the topography lines so if
you look at a Beaver Dam from above and
then you were to Overlay a topo line map
yeah sufficient detail that damn you
know every decision that they made
making that would overlay well with
topography well it makes sense because
water is self-leveling exactly so all
you have to do is make a decision the
next inch over yeah you know right and
so then they'll chase that usually to
the valley edges and then those things
start going up and then some of that
blows out but then they catch it down
lower and so it's back to it being a
process right like yeah the dam itself
um
very quickly if this process is working
you can't point to and say this is the
dam in a simplified system it's really
easy to say well that's the primary Dam
that's the dam that they use to back up
water over their Danning situation these
are auxiliary dams these are just
facilitating habitat right yeah but then
as soon as it actually really starts
working
it's all kind of unclear well I feel
better now that I didn't spot that that
Wetland near uh near Evergreen yeah
suggests that it's more mature and
developed yeah it was definitely it was
definitely a long-standing
um spot pretty pretty nifty
um is there before we move on from this
topic is there anything more on uh
Beaver natural history that we ought to
know you've talked about The Lodges
talked a bit about the dams
um I would point out that they're
vegetarians
um
yeah they're vegetarians but they're not
annoying about it no no they uh it's a
terrible
they're kind of like you know that that
family and the neighborhood who they
homeschool and they're vegetarians and
they're like obsessively gardening all
the time yes and they have huge Tails
everyone else is just like they might be
onto something but we can't quite tell
what's going on in there right yeah yeah
that's the Beavers that's the Beavers
yeah we kind of look in and we're like
you know are they simple are they the
deepest thinkers on the Block right you
know right we don't know yeah
um so in tales of Narnia the Beavers
serve fish to the lost children and I
don't know if that's the origin of the
rumor that beavers eat fish
um but there's a pretty pronounced rumor
that beavers eat fish and you know they
don't they're vegans I think the more
interesting part of the tales of Narnia
is it's actually the Beavers that are
guiding Humanity through this
landscape that is having an ecological
crisis
um uh you know if we're gonna draw any
of that now right inside phone yeah
getting distracted by I mean they were
also I think drinking beer too so uh
gotta pass the time somehow I know yeah
um yeah I feel like we covered diet and
uh the one thing that uh in the Natural
History piece that
people don't necessarily notice first
too is that beavers dig a lot and you
probably saw this when the dam collapsed
but the Topography is highly complex
it's not just a basin of mud when a dam
there's movement channels and mud has
been moved here and scraped away from
there and the canals that go out into
the landscape to facilitate you know
beavers knock something down but it's 40
yards away from the creek well they can
float it out on the canal and so they're
doing a lot of digging as well and when
you Wade through a beaver dam or damned
area at Beaver Pond what you'll notice
is the temperature differences are
pretty staggering you'll be in a really
cold area and then you move into a
really warm area and then you'll back be
back and cold you know all in the same
Pond to us it just looks like a pond
yeah right and there's complex things
happening with upwelling because of all
the water being forced down into the
landscape where you know there's I guess
the other persistent kind of
um Mark against beavers people will try
it out as well don't they warm the water
that's a lot of solar radiation you're
collecting right but they're missing a
below ground process where this water is
sinking in and upwelling and when you
start thinking about
like the frogs that need to overposite
in a warm shallow place but also the
salmon fry that need a cold deep spot
yeah with cover
um
it you can kind of start to pee at why
this has worked you know for all these
various life forms that need various
types of habitat they're creating
diverse opportunities in a single in the
single Wetland yeah and we get used to
measuring streams in like linear miles
but if we were honest about what a
healthy stream looks like it should be
Acres you know right
it's not a line it's not a line and
there was a good paper where they took a
bunch of stream professionals at a
conference somewhere and they're like
draw a healthy stream you know here's a
piece of paper and a pencil and
consistently everybody drew a squiggly
line that kind of did a little snake
thing
and these were the professionals right
and so the blind spot is
is pronounced you know the the healthy
stream that is this sponge of habitat
so is this why
um
The Meadows in
upper Yosemite look the way they do I
don't know I haven't spent much time
with them I mean it's unbelievable it's
like they're almost
um beyond their beauty is so staggering
right these just large
uh it you know it it looks like somebody
with a very good eye has
um made the most you know glorious I'm
trying to avoid analogizing them to
to a manufactured habitat but it just
it's it's it
trains credulity how lovely these places
are but now that you talk about this it
does strike me
um
as likely to have been a process that
sort of took the you know the relatively
small Bounty of these very cold streams
running through uh the upper parts of
Yosemite and drove it out yeah
horizontally yeah yeah that's the that's
the kind of
ironic thing here is
those systems that are being maintained
in these processes whether it was people
burning or it was beavers flooding yeah
we find those aesthetically beautiful
right but
um I've still done away with both of
those processes on mass right right
we're dealing with the encroachment and
the
uh degradation that results from that
well we made we made the error that is
maybe at the heart of
um
of our culture which is too too young in
some sense to become wise about this but
we took that gorgeous thing and we
consumed it you know and we were still
consuming it and
um
I I think it's very clear in in the
story that you tell but
we ought to be
like the Beavers replenishing it right
because
it is you know it is the stuff that high
quality life is made out of and
yeah and you know it there's a there's
an uplifting piece of that and that
um I meet a lot of people who are
struggling with feeling
like where is my niche as a human
right yeah yeah this like this guilt or
the shame or fear
um all these emotions that are seated in
the present or the past right but where
where's my spot
um where do I fit in
and
I think as I've been advocating we need
to defer to the professionals when it
comes to Water Systems that's not our
spot yeah
um but
people were burning the Uplands and
maintaining just like Beaver predictable
habitat for the rest of the ecology for
our own purposes right yeah facilitating
better forage
um
that's the spot you know I've friends
down in Europe country who are still
doing it the way that they've been doing
for a thousand years and those folks are
very generous and in teaching other
humans all right you ready to listen now
you know all right let's let's talk this
is how it so so we have a we have a role
to play just as much as beavers that you
know they're they're there are forests
that need tending yep with flame
um and so yeah I think I think there's
there's two parts there it's like
there is a role for us but we need to we
need to be clear-eyed about which of the
complex evolved systems we had a role in
and it wasn't the water yeah that's
interesting
um I do think that some of the wiser
conservationists that I have known have
had a sense that there's a kind of
fetishizing of nature that is
counterproductive and that basically all
you know even the Amazon We Now
understand was much more managed than we
knew right it's not a an untouched
habitat it's an intensively touched
habitat but
we can take a lesson from that and I
think there there are two lessons in
tension one is we should manage these
things to the benefit of humanity going
forward
but two managing them means as light a
touch as possible and you know sometimes
as light a touch as possible may not be
any you know
using fire is not all that light a touch
it should be done well but it may need
to be done light touch but consistent
with
what the prop the process that's led to
our current ecology right uh you know
yes if we're going to do novel things
then we really need to be careful yeah
yeah absolutely and I was actually going
to mention that when you were talking
about those two towns having burned down
that one of the things that happens when
stuff burns down is it doesn't just burn
down but it liberates all the toxins
that were involved in that thing yeah
they go everywhere right you breathe
them they end up in the plants they it's
terrible yep um but in the case you know
maybe fire is a place where a slightly
heavier hand is necessary but it needs
to be done in a way that does not
disrupt those equilibria and with
respect to water let the experts deal
with it I like that approach I think
that that makes good sense it requires
some humility which sometimes we as a
species struggle with yeah I've noticed
that pattern of honest yeah
um so all right let me before we close
this out
um I think there's another thing that's
probably
worth exploring a little bit
Evergreen has been misunderstood because
for most people it didn't exist in their
minds until they saw it go crazy uh in
the episode that actually brought
Heather and and me to to prominence and
that has always been a bit of a bitter
pill for us because Evergreen
was
simultaneously an amazing place
and
um a tragic failure to live up to its
potential and you know before Evergreen
blew up
we were
basically voices shouting into the wind
about the central flaw of the place
right we wanted to cure it and there was
no appetite for curing it and I wanted
to just say what I think it was and then
talk a little bit about your experience
because frankly I think if people got to
know
some of the folks who had graduated from
Evergreen and gotten something out of it
they would have a very different sense
that this wasn't a demonstration that a
radical departure from the educational
model was inherently a mistake because
it wasn't so the flaw
as I see it well the beauty I used to
say Evergreen was uh they the founders
threw out absolutely everything from a
normal university or college and
replaced it with something else and half
of what they did was brilliant and half
of it was crazy and that the only
problem was that we never got around to
saying all right which which fraction
doesn't work and getting rid of that
that would have been a perfectly good
process that would be the next step in
the experiment right it sure should have
been yeah so the biggest flaw that I see
all right the biggest value was that
professors were liberated to teach
whatever they wanted to teach in
whatever they way they wanted to teach
it which sounds like a recipe for
disaster but the fact is if you're
interested in teaching and the place was
founded around the idea that teaching
should be Paramount right
but if you had an appetite to figure out
what could be done that nobody had ever
done before in a classroom then you
could do it you could figure it out and
what people viewers most of them will
not know
is that that structure involved what
were called full-time programs where you
as a student take one class full-time
professor teaches one class full-time
and those programs could go on for a
full year
and what that does especially with the
the low uh professor to student ratio
was are they high professor to student
range really low student Professor ratio
but the uh what that does is it means
that professors and students know each
other very very well right right
and it means that the professor if they
have an appetite for it can figure out
you know even down to the individual
mind in the classroom what does that
person hung up on right you know you
know what's going on and and that
process is potentially great yeah right
that was the awesome part bad part was
and I would add to that yeah that
um some of those full-time
uh programs were taught by multiple
professors from across discipline so and
just painting the picture that was
that was part of it too yep right it
could be it would sometimes be a team of
two or three professors
that are
ushering the same group of students
through a program for a year yeah team
teaching and
um those programs were often students
didn't know this but those programs were
just inventions right one Professor sits
down next to another professor someday
and they have a conversation in which
they're each focused on their own thing
and it's like well actually this
conversation's pretty good I wonder if
we could build a program around that
yeah yeah
um the bad part though
is
you get hired at Evergreen it's not
obvious
that just because you've got a PhD
somewhere in some subject that you're
going to be any good at all at figuring
out how to teach if you're completely
free
right lots of people aren't
and
so what I would have done if I had had
the ability to to fix it
is after you're hired there's a period
of three years maybe maybe it would be
five years in which you have to
demonstrate that you can figure out what
to do with all that freedom and if at
the end of that period you're doing a
great job and students are feeling
really you know energized by what you're
doing right you stay and if you can't
figure it out in that period of time it
doesn't matter how much we like you you
should go right because that spot that
you're in that is a you know Evergreen
The Faculty used to say
didn't pay in money it paid in Freedom
right those were glorious positions not
because of what they paid but basically
because if you were if you had a taste
for the work right it was rewarding you
knew what you knew why you were there
every day right
um and so by not having that process in
which we selected for people who
actually were good at figuring out what
to do with freedom it resulted in
basically there were some professors who
were great and there were some
professors who basically used it as an
excuse not to work right so anyway
for somebody who clearly got a lot out
of the thing
um I'd be interested to know what you
know what you're overarching you you
were how many classes with Heather and
me did you take just the one just the
one yeah yeah animal behavior and
zoology animal behavior and zoology yeah
you were co-teaching it together yeah
which I know you didn't always Teach as
a team but that that year you're
teaching it's a team yeah we taught us a
team that year which we did a number of
times
um and then we also had the experience
of teaching separately and there was a
group of students who would bounce from
one of our programs to the other right
there was like a large group of students
who were who had become interested in
evolution as a result of the fact that
there were two of us you know teaching
related topics and we had very different
styles and anyway that seemed to work
for a lot of people even to the point
that
many students
would continue to show up for class even
after they were no longer registered
with one of us even sometimes after they
graduated because they got so used to
the idea that there was a community of
people who spoke the same language that
they would I think I did that one year I
came through Olympia and
I found out you were teaching in a
lecture hall and I sat in on a lecture
on gay dinosaurs gay dinosaurs yes
right yeah that would have been a
lecture that
um
that was part of a two-part lecture that
I did where a student Colin
was quite paleontologist
paleontologically expert had teamed up
with me uh and so basically it was about
the evolution of homosexuality and I did
the human part of it which was a topic I
had become interested in and he did a
kind of survey of other things and and
the you know the grand finale was gay
Dynasty which you know it's amazing that
clearly stuck with me yeah right if you
remember it all these years later but
all right so um what was your experience
at Evergreen to the extent that people
don't understand what the place was what
can you tell them
yeah well so
the hazard you identify was clear to me
and I think to most of the students too
you know you'd have this this thing
called the academic Fair
where all the professors are sitting at
individual tables and you as a student
have the opportunity to decide where am
I going to commit an entire year of my
education yeah that's a risky business
in that if you hit a stinker
big West it's a big waste and so that's
was both the
um
the strength and the weakness of this
back to your get rid of the folks who
don't know what to do with this
um I was in a navigator trying to
navigate a landscape where there were
folks who knew what to do with it and
folks who didn't and as a student you're
coming into it
and you're trying to assess
um
and and often the folks who didn't know
what to do with it their classes were
wait listed there was a vicious process
of trying to get in I mean I know with
you and Heather you always had wait
lists people were trying to get in
people were writing you love letters you
know so many please please please right
um
but once you were once you were in that
cohort and you were invested for a year
I mean you could do fantastic stuff you
could go take the entire cohort out of
state for months on end yeah because why
why they don't have anything else
they're committed to doing they don't
have anything else everybody doing yeah
and like if you don't need the lab then
right why you know
um so
I thought that was
I loved Evergreen I came to it with
someone who as someone too who had a
severe tracking difficulty
um which you know I eventually worked on
but like if I'm reading music or
whatever at the time I'd go one two five
oh back here you know which made it
difficult yeah yeah
um
Evergreen was a place where those of us
who had those sorts of
um
you know different different ways
learning learning disabilities right or
whatever you want
um
it you could just kind of sweep it aside
because it was a very different model it
was like well where are you at on the
content you know and there's many ways
to approach understanding the content
um I remember uh so after your class I
went to a class that was kind of pre-med
school you know we got really deep in
all the pre-medical subjects and
um it was kind of stressful because it
was like you know oh you're gonna be a
doctor or not even at Evergreen they
still somehow cultivated that Vibe
um so
I would get stressed out and take my
fiddle down to a local pub every
Wednesday night and play Irish Tunes
with folks there was like a bottomless
picture of dark ale and light ale for
anyone who came in and could halfway
play an instrument
um
that was my little stress release I was
talking to an old guy there at the pub
and he's a I told him I was an evergreen
student he's like well yep Evergreen
that's a that's a school of deep divers
and floaters
um
which was kind of my experience too with
both teachers and students students yeah
you could choose to Deep dive and it was
risky and it was the promise of great
reward
or you can choose to like wear the water
wings and four years later you pop out
the other side yeah
it's value but it's the same degree that
any of the deep divers got too right and
there's this wonderful thing around
rather than grades you have the
evaluated evaluative process where I
write an evaluation view I said he was
great except for his hair
do the same and he was great except for
his hair right exactly and then they
match and then they match another
forever the record too right
um but that was that was pretty cool too
I I really appreciated that um
you know and and especially if you're
through the same program for multiple
terms you're doing this evaluation at
the end of every single term
um yeah yeah I'm I'm warned that that
doesn't seem to be there anymore it was
it was an amazing thing
um
uh and I I really got a lot out of it I
got a lot out of it from you and Heather
um I got a lot out of it the next year
uh I was able to do another independent
study
um on Wales with a local
uh graduate who started one of the
Premier Research collectives in whale
biology
um and I know who you're talking about
but you might be yeah John calma kiddis
the Cascadia research Collective I you
know he he and a number of Evergreen
grads this is what you could do with an
evergreen education right he they
graduated with bachelor's degrees
and they started an independent science
Collective yeah you know which is
important in well research and actually
bat research in in uh yeah in the Puget
Sound yeah yeah and uh it because it
cultivated like I don't actually have to
ask permission to do this right and
that's the thing is because of the
freedom right if you couldn't figure out
what to do with it as a student then
maybe you didn't get anything out of the
process but if you did you know get your
bearings then the point is you came out
of it with something that was a lot
closer to what graduate school would
give you where you knew how to get stuff
done you didn't need somebody to tell
you to do it well and I'll admit I uh
when I was in your class
I pretended to be a glad student many
times
um probably
uh
mostly so so we were
in Olympia for two terms and then I went
to Panama
and it was an example of what you can do
right I proposed a research project out
on this island 14 kilometers out into
the Caribbean I said I want to work on
the pygmy three-toed sloth
and Heather was my advisor she said okay
um and uh you know we ended up I
persuaded a few more students to come
with me on this crazy adventure and we
ended up uh doing the first population
census as a critically endangered
species I never got the thing published
all of that
um
and I didn't even think about like oh
you're not supposed to do that as an
undergrad yeah except for when I would
try to access like the resources at the
Smithsonian Institute in Panama
um in which case they would let me in if
I pretended to be a grad student
but undergrads you know it was a tour
experience that it's funny I don't know
uh you I don't know that we ever talked
about this
um or if we did whether you'll remember
it but I think the reason that you ended
up on pygmy sloths actually had to do
with
um my correct the description of the
pygmy sloth was a Charles Handley
paper it was Charles Hanley but that
wasn't actually the connection oh it
wasn't yeah I was I was interested in
antillion manatees
so I started calling all the researchers
down there on manatees
and I was like all right how do I get
what are the questions what is what are
people puzzling on and uh
I ran into this one guy who said well
you know manatees might be hard to tap
in with but there's the sloth there's
the sloth on this island and then yes
the descriptive paper Charles Handley he
was one of my mentors on bats actually
on Borough Colorado Island in Panama
he's now gone but um anyway I think he
would have been very pleased that you
guys
um went and and studied this very odd
creature on this island
um in the Boca Del Toro inhospitable
little island but um yeah yeah way the
hell out there
um yeah and we were talking about
phenolic compounds earlier the the pygmy
sloth is a funny puzzle because they
seem to specialize on only Mangrove
leaves yeah and you don't see that as we
were talking about with grazers and
browsers or browsers rather because
they're trying to
distribute the toxins right amongst many
different types
um but yeah yeah it's an interesting
puzzle and interesting that you were
able you know yeah as an undergraduate
you're able to you know not only manage
an actual research project that was able
to get to the point of a you know a
useful and publishable
um paper but to do so under really
inhospitable
conditions right that's an amazing
accomplishment three months in a pretty
remote place yeah pretty remote but
that's what that's what Evergreen
enabled there was no one to say no right
right
you had you had a guiding Mentor in your
faculty and as long as you could
convince them that you know there was
there was some hope that you would come
through it with something that uh is
worth the education yeah yeah and I and
I learned a lot from that experience
well you mentioned
um academic Fair which to be honest with
you I haven't thought about it in some
time but I used to love that it's very
stressful as a student that was the
dating game I used to I used to love it
because and most faculty hated it right
you had to show up on a day when you
would otherwise have been free in the
afternoon and sit there for hours you
know as one student after another would
come and sit down in front of you and
say well what what's your program going
to be about but
for me it was an opportunity
to this is going to sound terrible but
because our classes were for both
Heather and me our classes were always
oversubscribed and that meant that there
was actually something to be
accomplished in figuring out what
students would be best if they got in
their questions had the most to gain
from it and what students brought
something to the table that would make
the programs Lively
and so
um you know I wouldn't just deliver the
same you know what's your program going
to be about well we're going to study
this that and the other right I would
use it as an opportunity to figure out
who was sitting down in that chair in
front of me and figure out whether or
not they were a good fit and if they
were a good fit I would do everything in
my power to try to get them to sign up
and if they weren't going to be a good
fit because they really needed you know
a syllabus and they needed to know on
what day that you know if that was what
was going to happen then I was not I was
doing them a favor by driving them off
right
um and so anyway I you know
many of the people who took my programs
and went on uh to do really interesting
things and to become friends and people
that I admire I met them at academic
Fair as they thought they were
interviewing me and I was kind of
pushing them around to see whether they
could you know could handle it and
whether or not it was going to be the
kind of thing that was to their taste so
anyway I have many fond memories of that
um yeah I remember I had to write a
essay on trade-offs in order to get into
your class oh were you um you must have
been you weren't uh you didn't get in on
the normal I was I was late to
um uh signing up right and I didn't
attend academic fair right
and so then I was assigned an essay and
signed an essay right
um yeah that's cool
yeah so I mean I don't I don't
my hope is that by the time my three
little ones are at the age where they're
looking for
a mentor of that caliber there's a place
where mentors have that freedom
um I don't know where that is right now
but it's nowhere right now yeah
um I I hope it happens too I of course
have one kid right at that age and one
kid a couple years out and
um the fact that there's nowhere obvious
to send them is so disturbing and you
know it is
it is evidence of exactly the same kind
of short-sightedness as we were
discussing with respect to the
destruction of all of the things that
the Beavers had built into our
Landscapes because
we are effectively sowing the seeds of
our undoing by allowing education to be
captured by
ideological agendas and uh
just lunacy right I mean how crazy is it
that a place
you know that produced really great
students who were capable of
you know I mean like you founded an
organization
um you are now uh returning to your
former professor and teaching him about
uh
you know important features of the life
of a mammal even though he's a
mammologist right so anyway that kind of
um
liberating encounter with education is
tremendously important
there is you know people
totally misunderstand you know Evergreen
is a public college right yeah why which
was one of the reasons I could attend I
was on Pell Grant and food stamps you
know and wasn't a place for rich kids
it's not that there weren't a few there
there were for sure but it was a place
it was inexpensive to afford you could
if you you know if you had a learning
disability it wasn't the end of the
world there was 1100 Acres of forest I
came back from Panama I was like I'm not
gonna do a renting a lease thing and I
lived in the forest for the rest of time
did you oh you I didn't realize you I
was one of those students yeah
maintained three different lockers and
showered in the gym yeah this is one of
these things that happens at Evergreen
it was it was a truly special place and
you know
it's it's very upsetting to me that it's
um Legacy is that the lunacy
staged coup which it did but that was
not the sum total of the story of the
place and
for those wishing to build you know
higher ed 2.0
understanding whatever green had right
would be crucial yeah right if you could
take the part that Evergreen had right
and
prune off the part that didn't work
right then you've got the seed of
something really powerful and you know
you're a testament to that and I uh I
greatly appreciate what you did with the
the freedom that you had uh as a result
of going there well thanks
um as you're saying that I'm reminded
um
kind of the process that Twitter is
going through right now where
they seem to be pruning things that
aren't working and trying to retain
things that work
um which
yeah it's kind of a non-sequitur but it
it
I know that you spend a bit of time
there and so and I don't so it'd be kind
of interested on your thoughts here but
my experience with that platform and as
a Public Square
um
I was a little leery of the app so I had
a browser open on my phone and I had
um multiple tabs
each tab was some thinker that I was
interested in their take right
because the way Twitter was working you
couldn't actually you know you're
following 100 people you couldn't say
these 12 people I want to check in with
what they said
right but I did that by a bunch of tabs
and that was my that was my news filter
for a long time until Twitter did away
with the ability to open it on a browser
and the way I was doing but the the
ability to check in on a daily basis and
say okay what's Brett saying what's his
brother saying and then go down the list
um
was a powerful
news filter
as I was struggling to understand the
world and feeling like I'm being sold a
bill of goods everywhere I turn the one
spot that I was able to find
um
a place where I could I could get kind
of a thinking person's perspective but
then across various political Spectrum
you know 20 minutes later I knew what
all these various Minds were thinking
about whatever the issue that had come
up was
um I thought that that was a really
powerful piece that I think is very
promising and that you know
I'm curious like well as one of those
people you know
this is a very dangerous moment and I
did not even think to do what you're
discussing doing it strikes me as you
know it's tragic that you have to right
that you want is one or a couple of
sources of news where they have
effectively done that and they have
figured out what the various
perspectives are and they present it in
some way that doesn't require you to
clooge together a solution like that
however
that's not the world we live in so I
know when some story is happening
I am constantly in the the bind that I
then think all right
which news Outlet is liable to be able
to report that story straight I want to
know what's going on there's no news
outlet that is capable of reporting all
stories as straight as they can get them
they all have a bent and so the point is
on that story
all right is that a story that the New
York Times can afford to report or is
that a story that they will be telling
me complete nonsense and so you're
describing a solution to that problem
built of individuals right here's some
individuals who
um you know have a track record I'm not
going to listen to any of them in
individually exactly the powers in the
Aggregate and yeah broadly spreading out
who you're listening to so what I would
say is I am very hopeful about what musk
seems to be up to and I'm very nervous
about it because a lot depends on him
getting it right and I guess I hope that
he will hear what you were doing and
hear that it is no longer possible
because the app effectively forbids it
it's driving people to the app is so
much a part of Twitter yeah yeah I open
on the browser it says well we've got an
app you know right so the question is
look there's no reason as far as I can
tell that the app since musk does appear
to be interested in people using this as
a source of news which sounds crazy but
in this era I think it's actually the
best hope we've got
there's no reason that that couldn't be
done in the app what you need is control
and in fact
many of us have been in a sort of
private conversation about what might be
done to make an environment that didn't
drive us crazy and one of the things
that might be done is the ability to
peer through anybody's eyes at the thing
part of the problem with something like
Twitter is that I know what it shows me
right I have to bend over backwards to
figure out how well that matches what it
shows somebody else and I certainly
can't see you know I I don't have a set
of controls that allow me to go in
and say you know toggle right yeah let
me see this Through The Eyes of an NPR
listener right I'd love to know right
but I can't do it I'm too trapped in my
own uh my own bubble
um so anyway the idea of you were
colluding something together it's clear
that there's such a value it's clear
that musk wants people to be using it
this way and there's now a structural
obstacle to doing it maybe that results
in him thinking huh how can we build
that into the app so that instead of
um you know being uh short-sighted and
you know milking people's attention we
can be far-sighted and we can give them
the opportunity to do something that is
so valuable from the point of view of
building their perspective on the world
that that will keep them around long
term even if they look at it for fewer
hours yeah exactly because you were
doing work for me right if I tune into
12 perspectives I don't know how many
hours you spent too many
but I am I am a parasitic uh recipient
benefiter from the amount of hours you
spent coming up with your and I I read
it in 30 seconds and then I'm moving on
to the next person and the next person
and that is a powerful that's a powerful
tool yep yeah you say I know you're
joking when you say parasitic I have to
tell you though that it is exactly the
opposite of the right thing because
um in my case
I confess I would be better off if it
wasn't on Twitter but I can't not be and
the reason that I am there is because it
is necessary to do the kind of sense
making that I do and it is necessary
um
to provide something useful to other
people right if people are going to
listen to what I have to say then it
ought to be informed and there isn't a
good place to go get informed that
doesn't look like a Cluj
so I use it as a tool I'd love a better
tool and I'd love for people like you
who are using it as a tool to
be able to do it deliberately right just
set in motion here are the perspectives
I would like to be able to scan between
so I want a tool not an experience yeah
right right yeah yeah and actually this
uh this goes to
one of my I won't call it a pet peeve
but one of my concerns
is that too many phenomena that where we
interact with something have been turned
into consumer phenomena you know you
don't want to be a consumer of Twitter
right you want a tool with which you can
discover something interact in ways that
are useful and turn it off at the point
that it's not benefiting you and uh you
know it will be the first of its kind if
it becomes that yeah
yeah
all right well
um this has been fabulous it's great to
see you and it's great to see you making
your way in the world and on such a
important if strange topic as uh Beaver
well-being and terraforming terraforming
of the earth to our benefit
so Jacob Shockey it's been a pleasure
thank you thank you
[Music]
foreign